Where I will.
I've already,
yes,
that's ridiculous.
Hey fuckers,
are you doing?
Um,
listen.
Do you need a website?
Build it yourself.
Don't be a lazy bitch.
You can do it on.
Normally I would say he can't do it,
but you can do it if you go to Squarespace.
I know he's saying Joe Rogan.
I'm stupid.
Of course you are.
I'm stupid to w we could be sleeping together.
It's all right.
Trust me.
You can make this happen.
Go to squarespace.com and check out how easy it is to create your own custom
website,
custom images and content.
You could choose from over 20 bad ass designs if you need help.
They offer 24 seven super fast email support and live online chat support.
It's very easy,
so easy that I can make a website me and you can too.
It used to be that you had to learn how to code or learn how to use some fucking
wanky ask program that would make you want to pull your hair out if you have
any.
But nowadays you can just go to squarespace.com hook that shit up yourself.
There are so confident that it's an excellent way to create a website that you
can do it without even using your credit card.
You can go there,
just try it out and no credit card needed.
Start building your own website and then if you decide you like it,
then use the code Joe and the number eight.
Oh yeah,
we forgot we'd wait
all the way.
We got roll a joint
that God,
nobody can see us once a month.
I'm good.
Thank you sir.
So easy.
You could do it.
Do you know how to roll on these things?
Do you know how to use this?
Can you do it?
Jimmy,
do this while we're talking.
I can't believe we forgot.
It's been so long.
You've been,
I don't know.
I don't know what I'm doing anymore.
In a way.
It shouldn't be waiting there.
If there's not,
we're fucked.
Figure it out.
We'll go.
So want,
we'll have halfway sober.
Squarespace starts to just eight bucks a month,
including a free domain name.
If you sign up for a year.
So go to squarespace.com use the offer code,
all one word Joe.
And the number eight.
That's Joe the number eight.
All one word,
save yourself 10% is an excellent resource.
If you want to create a website,
I can't recommend it enough.
You can use the site,
will look great on any device.
IPAD,
iPhone,
android,
they got it hooked up and you can also create your own online store like that.
It's super easy.
Brian has literally created dozens of websites while we've done these ads.
It's so easy.
Connected accounts,
you can easily connect to Twitter,
Facebook,
Linkedin,
all that other stupid shit.
Instagram,
Google,
Blab,
blab.
But I,
but I,
but I go to squarespace.com.
Use the code Joe Eight,
save yourself some cash.
You dirty bitches.
Um,
as far as comedy dates coming up,
we got a lot.
My,
my,
my show is done and so I'm back on the road suite bitches.
Um,
Brian,
you said you're doing something with the Great Thompson Gaura and the Great
Christina Palicki in Columbus.
Yeah,
we just,
it just went on sale.
We're doing a super show out there.
Tom Sicara.
Christina is,
that's gay tongue.
Tony Hinchcliffe and me at the woodlands back yard in Columbus,
Ohio.
And the day before me and Tony are going to be an Arizona.
It's stand up live so you can go death squad.
Dot TV for all the tickets.
Nice and Arizona.
That place is fucking awesome and huge.
Huge.
600 people.
She'll be scared,
should always be scared.
It's a hard thing to fill up.
She'd be scared of it.
Keeps you on your feet,
keeps you sharp.
On uh,
this weekend,
uh,
August 30th,
I'll be in Milwaukee,
Wisconsin With Mad Flavor,
Aka Joey Diaz.
And uh,
this Wednesday night we're at the ice house.
Wednesday night,
10:00 PM.
I haven't booked any people on the show yet,
but it will be me and a bunch of people from town.
So it's always great comics.
We have a lot of people that are funny shit that live in this area.
So go there and get your freak on.
Um,
higher primate.com is a restocked.
So all the new shit,
uh,
the,
run jre shirts that you see me wearing on Joe Rogan,
questions,
everything.
And,
uh,
and you know,
all the ones that have worn on the show as well.
The gas,
my gas mask,
monkey chimp shirt,
all that stuff.
Higher prime is my a tee shirt company.
It's all just monkeys and psychedelics.
The things I'm interested in most other than you,
people I love the fuck are you guys were also brought to you by [inaudible] dot
com.
That's o.
N.
I.
T.
If you haven't been there awhile,
we have,
uh,
the new,
Carrillo kettle bells in,
uh,
we also have an orangutan on the way that I just got.
I got it at home.
It's fucking dope.
Alicia's,
we got to this primal bell company.
We're expanding this line,
but it's,
uh,
it's quite complicated because we've,
decided to make these really dope looking kettle bells with these designs in
them that are also functional and balanced.
So,
um,
if you get like,
uh,
I know there's other companies that have designs that they put in Kettlebells,
but what they didn't do is make it so that the kettle bell is perfectly
balanced.
I think it's a very important thing.
If you're swinging around these big,
heavy fucking iron things,
you want to make sure that there's not some imbalance in the way you use it.
That would kind of defeat the purpose of having a kettle bell.
It should be not just a functional or not just beautiful,
but functional as well.
Uh,
so if you go there and you can check out all the different fitness equipment we
have battle ropes,
steel maces,
steel clubs,
ab wheels,
so you can get yourself a sexy six pack like Tj Dillashaw bitch we got,
we got medicine balls,
all that good shit as well as a a fuck load of supplements,
including of course Alpha brain and shroom tech sport.
You ever used the shroom tech sport,
right,
sir?
That's the shit.
I love all that stuff.
T plus to get your pecker all ready for action,
go to [inaudible] dot com use the code name or Rogan and save yourself 10% of
any and all supplements.
And then it's a beautiful too.
It's fucking
lot.
A lot of cool shit there does give you a boners right?
Fucking it does.
Absolutely increases testosterone and you're,
you're allowed to drink on this cause I've noticed you can't do boner pills and
alcohol lately.
So I've been having a bad no,
why not?
I don't know.
We even something bad for your heart I think because it takes all your blood and
takes it,
puts it in your Dick and then like your heart's like,
Hey,
I don't have enough blood group to deal with this Jack Daniels science by Red
Band.
Yeah.
Well see red band doing a ted conference.
Basically it takes all the blood and puts it in your deck.
You picking your heart just explodes or something.
I don't know.
I just read it so I kind,
I kind of freaked out because that's what,
that was like the best Combo Ever Jack and you can still do it.
You want a lot of shit that's bad for you,
right.
I'll call itself is fucking terrible for you.
It's not like as a vitamin.
No,
he drinking until you black out four nights a week and you're worried about what
boner pills are going to add to the equation.
I just wanted to have teeth will give me the same kind of rock hard boner.
I don't know what you did in a past life,
but you're almost fucking 40 you look like you're 12 and you're getting hammered
every night.
He got great genes.
Don't worry about it.
Just take a multivitamin every now and then.
If you remember and keep riding until the fucking wheels fall off.
Don't worry about it.
Pitch.
We're here for a long time.
Don't worry.
Did I talked to Ray Kurzweil?
It's all gonna work out.
Alright.
Freaks.
Duane Ludwig,
Tj Dillashaw.
Both are in the building right now.
Enough with the commercials.
We're trying to shorten them down for your amusement.
So there,
that's the end.
And there's one more.
Dwayne Bang,
ludwig.com or doing bank.com [inaudible] dot com Dwayne bank.com bitches go
there by some Swedish shirts like this one here.
Hit it
all day.
It's actually better if you ever have anything to promote if you promoted after
the music because that's when it goes on.
Serious,
serious takes all this shit before the music and just puts it out there.
So I don't want to do with it.
Serious secret.
They throw it away.
Sometimes our best work was done before we even get started.
So then where do they go for us?
We got shirts are wearing,
they go to Duane pang.com than an affiliate bang,
Moy,
Tai,
uh,
Dwayne and Tj and I just got back from a garage training session.
Old School like Gracie in action 1993.
Yeah,
I got Matt set up in my garage.
We have a suite workout.
That was fun man.
It really cool.
Set up.
You have,
you're really enthusiastic man.
I could tell you like really enjoying this transition from being a professional
fighter to being a professional coach.
And a for folks who don't know,
Dwayne,
uh,
for a long time had fastest knockout in UFC history was tried.
They tried to deny you,
but we would not let them.
We forced that shit down their throat.
They will.
They were trying to give it to a,
to Todd Duffy who had a very fast knockout,
no doubt about it was pretty close,
but you still had them.
You edge them.
But the referee fucked up,
you know,
they gave it to you like 10 seconds,
but it's really like six right on the clock is at four.
But there for the duration of the balance from the bell sounds to the rest of
the start or a fight and then told one of the refs or to the ref touches one of
the opponents.
Right.
So from start to touch,
that's what we count.
Correct.
Okay.
So even if the bell rings before,
so they start just the bell ringing,
the beginning boxing it used to,
it doesn't,
but then my may.
Right.
And just say fine.
Yeah.
I don't even know how the fuck do I not know.
Why don't we hear him?
I don't hear if Tj [inaudible].
Here we go.
Try it again.
Yeah.
I'm,
we usually too amped up to even hear a bell.
Do you hear when you're out there,
do you hear Dwayne in your corner cheering it?
Yeah,
I can hear him.
I can hear Justin buckles usually the most,
cause he's real loud and he's always in my corner.
And then Duane as well.
Yeah.
So that's all you hear.
Just that.
And then the rest is just noise for the most part.
I mean you can hear like when the crowd gets excited,
you kind of hear that.
But you know,
you don't pay attention to it.
You know,
you just kinda try to focus in what you're supposed to.
Have you ever been in a fight where they booed?
No,
that's a weird moment,
right?
When when dudes are not doing anything and you know that they can hear it,
you know,
because there's never a boo during a wild scramble.
Right.
And the wild scrambles,
I would imagine the ones where you have the least memory of what the fuck is
going on,
like sound wise,
just saw.
So like tuned into it.
Right.
So it was what you asked me if we hear them booing.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
I have.
I've heard both for sure.
100%.
Do you,
do you feel responsibility when you hear that?
Like what's your feeling?
A little bit.
Just depends on the game plan on the fight and what's going on.
Yeah.
And you know,
cause sometimes the game plan couldn't be to just sit back and let him come to
us and you know,
let her go,
you know,
and I go fuck Lynn.
Right,
right,
right.
Kind of me running into some stupid,
that's sweet.
So it could be like,
like who's who's going to crack first?
Like who's going to give to these Bu's and do something stupid that gets off of
their game.
That's the main thing with these fires of myself is to control our own emotions.
Cause if you don't control us,
how are we going to control them?
And that's just one of those things.
If the crowd's going to boo and you know,
make this guy make a stupid mistake or to finally come in or you know,
coming to our game plan or whatever the scenario may be,
then sweet.
No,
let the crowd dictate what he's going to do and the,
hopefully he makes a mistake,
let him run to us.
We keep our composure,
we stick to the game plan and adjust on the fly.
We make things happen.
You know,
I'm an unusual MMA fan and that I've probably seen like live,
I've seen,
you know,
more than a thousand fights and had to call them.
So I've been involved in so many different scenarios,
so many fights watching it play out like classic all time,
great MMA fights.
I've had the honor to call,
but I,
I,
I'm different in that I like boring styles,
man.
I like a dude who takes no damage and smothers guys and just imposes his will.
Like a lot of people used to give John Fitch a hard time.
I swear to God,
John Fitch to one of my favorite fighters to watch and people will yell at me,
they're like,
you're the fucking idiot.
He's ruining MMA or Ben Aspirin,
same thing Ben asking is one of my favorite fighters to watch,
gives Ben aspirins a fucking glove.
He just wraps a hold of you.
That's real.
Okay.
He's stifling,
really exciting,
energetic strikers.
I mean like who is it is a,
was that fucking guy that he fought the fucking hardcore striker
recently.
He fought this Russian dude and then before it he fought that guy that vice did
a piece on him,
a line.
Lyle,
what the fuck is,
he says,
I have no idea.
God Damn and I'm not up on Bella tour too much to pay attention.
I'll find the gentleman's,
the aspirins gotta be so strong,
man,
that guy's got to be unbelievably strong,
strong.
He seems to always be in the right place.
Yeah.
You know like these positioning is,
and it's also,
his paths are so weird.
Like usually when I'm watching a guy rolled,
like say like here's a real easy example of the guy's like a blue belt on the
ground and I'm watching this transition from like take down to like make an
amount of trying to make a mount or trying to get site control.
I can see what he's doing and I see it real obvious but with,
and I'm like,
why is he grabbing?
Oh,
that arm,
oh,
what the fuck?
How did he get there?
It's like he's doing this weird shit.
He's like going behind guys and getting under hooks on their back arm and
fucking wrenching them in weird ways that tying their legs up and he's,
he's always in a weird spot.
So you can't have this mother fucker off you if you watch any of his wrestling
matches 100% that he was like,
nothing like super technical but a funky guy.
Like he'd everything funky.
Well I think in his technical it's just technical in his way.
Exactly.
And so it's not like he doesn't know what he's doing.
He's like super successful at it.
It's not like he's just this guy that's sort of making up karate,
you know,
like we've all seen those kung fu videos where dudes are just making shit up.
You know,
I've gotten the mad at me before shit all the time,
but I mean this is a different kind of making shit up.
Like the guy throws a punch walk right here.
I tacked the liver with a monkey paws,
you know,
and they're like talking about different techniques that they do where you can
tell literally while they're doing it,
they're making it up as they go up.
You said it then,
the show on that,
Joe,
I can't believe you didn't do a fake Kung Fu big conflict.
That would have been fun.
As Fun.
I think if we did a second season,
that is one I would want to do those,
those dudes who do the crazy touches,
like if you ever seen the videos of the Kung Fu masters who just throw people
through the air with your hands,
there's a ghetto one where this,
this uh,
this dude and he,
I don't know what it is,
but it's,
it's a very,
he's a very ghetto looking character.
I mean,
not just because he's black,
but just the way he's black,
you know,
I'm talking about,
I mean,
the whole thing is it's a ghetto environment.
he's not an Idaho.
Okay.
And he's,
he's the row in these Kung Fu moves to these people and he's got them shaking
like,
like exaggerated,
like wobbling back and forth.
Like they're hit getting hit by a pulse from a movie.
And you're like,
what is going on here is,
are they crazy?
Like,
is this a,
is this massive doses?
Is this just a big scam or z really have magic power?
Like those are the possibilities.
I had a guy on this week's episode of Joe Rogan questions.
Everything who said that he can make people fart in church is that he,
he reverses the net.
He was hilarious.
He's the guy was fucking hilarious.
Um,
but he stood there and at one point in time he said he could get me to move back
and forth with his mind.
And he like tried to get me to,
I'm not going to tell you if it worked or it didn't work.
It didn't fucking work.
Of course didn't work.
Fuck is wrong with you.
Jesus Christ.
I couldn't lie to you like that.
Uh,
but the dude was convinced that he and I was,
while he's doing,
I was like,
what am I just given his guy and start moving and I can't believe I'm doing it?
Like what if I had to like stand firm?
I had to make sure,
I'm like,
I'm not fucking going anywhere.
This shit is not working on me.
But if you were like a person who is easily led,
like maybe the type of person who would be,
who join a cult type of person who like loses themselves and another person's
influence,
which is a real psychological dilemma.
Like the reason why cults work.
Like if you look,
look in the newspaper and you hear about some crazy,
call it where the,
the guy's fucking all the girls and you know,
it's got 13 year old wives and shit and 50 of them.
You Go,
how the hell did that happen?
It we don't know.
But it happens.
There's people that just fall under the spell.
So when you see someone doing that fucking crazy cheese shit and making people
fly through the air,
it's like,
wow,
like what's happening here?
Yeah,
it gets going back to like job pitch and aspirin.
Just have x,
you know,
all,
we all know we don't know everything,
but you got a lot more Marshall's information.
You understand what's going on,
you understand the scenario.
People are still stuck in the mind frame to see him.
Bloody wars.
So bossy.
I mean,
I admit that I'm,
I'm,
I'm very unusual and then I'm more than willing to watch some boring shit if it
has a potential of getting exciting,
even if it gets through the entire fight.
And then like in the third round,
dude figures out how to stuff to take down and lands a big shot.
Oh,
shadow or,
or Fitch gets his back and starts to put them away.
If it takes all this like 50% punches for three fucking rounds until there's an
explosive moment.
I liked that.
I liked that because I know that that guy,
the guy in the bottom does not want that to be happening,
but yet it's happening.
So that's real.
That's why I fucking hate standups.
And people be like,
you know,
man stood up to fucking,
you're going to fucking protect the sports sports socks if everybody's just
going to blink and hump.
No,
no,
that guy doesn't want to get blanket hop.
Do you understand that?
Like that is real.
You can't deny that that dude is holding that motherfucker down.
You can't deny it.
You can't just make them stand up if it's boring.
Tough Shit.
Get off the bottom.
I'm in favor of standups.
I should've saved me
if it wasn't for that.
[inaudible]
so I'm off for the standup
world.
Moy Thai champion,
one of the most technical strikers ever in MMA.
So of course you love the stand your ground games,
no joke,
but you're,
you're,
you know,
obviously you have a big advantage.
We have a big advantage.
You always had a big technical advantage.
Like,
um,
Amir from tough Marcella.
Yeah.
He,
he's a very like,
very good,
more tie fighter.
And that fight that you had with him was amazing because it was a perfect
example of your technical,
like he fought you in your world and there was just this clear technique
advantage,
like,
like the stuff that you were trying to show me today,
you like about movement and about throwing punches and closing distance and
being in the right ear and about really small spaces.
You leave the littlest,
one of the things you kept saying put your hands by your face.
If you don't,
then my hands would be at your face.
Which one would you like more?
It's like really simple,
really simple,
but very tactical.
And that like showed itself in that fight.
Cause a mirror is a very competent,
he's a very good fighter,
you know?
But you caught them early.
I think it was a left hook.
You heard him with a left hook and then you opened it up and then from that on
he was like,
you were just taking your shots.
It was your fight.
You were dictating the dance.
I love watching that man.
I,
you know,
I don't,
I don't need a knockout.
I appreciate knockouts.
Absolutely.
But I also appreciate people shutting people down.
I appreciate when a guy is like,
you know,
a mighty mouse,
used to get that rap,
but it was really just because he was fighting guys like Ian Mccall or because
he was fighting guys like Benevidez if fighting really fucking tough guys,
you're not going to put these guys away.
But you know,
we saw in his last fight against Moraga,
he's still trying to finish it like always.
And so like that fight,
like he beat Moraga for four rounds before he finished him,
but he's still finished.
I'm like,
he was,
he was beating him clearly,
but he still took them out.
If the finished didn't happen,
there'd be a lot of people that say,
oh,
I don't like watching mighty mouse fight.
You know,
it's fucking boring.
But no,
that's not boring at all.
It's awesome.
You just got to understand what you're watching art.
Right?
They're educated though.
Yeah.
I got hit once.
I mean literally got caught once,
one big shot in the fourth round and worked his way through it with no problem.
It's knows as fucking bleeding mean Maraca can bang.
And he caught that dude right on the chin.
So when you're dealing with is like he's a perfect specimen,
he's got everything,
he's got technique,
he's got heart,
he's got intelligence,
he always comes in and shape and he tries to finish the fight.
It's a fucking champion.
I mean mighty mouse is a fucking champion.
Great.
But I've heard people say,
oh,
you're going to work watching those little guys food and we don't even finish.
You said you don't even want to know what you're talking about.
You're just watching the best guys go at it.
And a lot of times they neutralize each other because the level of technique is
so fucking high at one 25 and one 35 Tj,
where you fight that fucking level of technique is through the roof.
A man
[inaudible] that's what,
that's a fun thing here at tema familiar here,
but they're in Timothy Medal.
You know,
everyone's been pointing finger me like come the secret pill and everything.
But I have world class athletes,
hundred percent world class athletes.
They don't get any better than these guys.
You know,
now they have what I feel is the proper information.
So here he got proper proper information with world class athletes.
They really have no choice but to get better.
It's pretty simple stuff,
you know,
and just like you did over the private today,
just simple,
basic stuff.
Newtown,
they understanding what they're doing and why they're doing it so they can
branch off from there.
But I'm definitely making sure that I'm tailoring to the athlete.
I'm not going to make them Duane Ludwig.
I want to make them better athletes from themselves,
you know?
But here's,
here's the correct way.
Okay,
you can make that way work.
Okay?
You can make it work.
Okay,
good.
Let's make it work.
Then add that to the system that that's your style.
Cool.
I'll adapt to you.
But just something like mighty mouse.
Can you teach somebody to be mighty mouse?
Some of the aspects,
but not all of it.
He's got to be as on athlete.
We're all individual athletes.
Just like your sidekick today,
and he's spinning kicks who are world class,
you know?
And that can be taught because we would take a million reps,
but correct reps as well and pay attention.
People have to know what they're doing and don't have to do it.
It's one of the things that Eddie Bravo is stresses about certain guard
techniques.
They're like,
well,
I keep doing it.
People keep breaking out of it.
Well,
when you learn like a wheel kick,
you don't learn how to nail people with it every time.
Most of the time you're gonna miss you going,
oh,
this doesn't work.
And then you'll get in there with Uriah hall or somewhere that level and then
we'll kick you in the face.
You Go,
oh my God,
this is the craziest technique ever.
It's a guaranteed knockout.
Me,
you literally hitting a guy with your whole fucking body behind a heel.
They go hard.
You goddamn he'll is.
I mean,
people break their knuckles all the time.
You ever break a heel now you don't break your healed.
So God damn hammer at the bottom of your foot and it's carrying your body wait
around all day and the amount of force it you could fuck.
But I ain't going to work right away.
You've got to learn how to do it.
It's like everything else,
like you got to do the reps until you get to that black belt level it,
and they're like,
there's some techniques that guys can do a in Jujitsu,
and the reason they can do it,
the reason why I think it,
like if a guy gets a nasty Darce,
like some people get Darcy and their arms a burnout and I never finish them.
But then there's those dudes that have that fucking razor Darce,
you know?
Oh yeah.
And they clamp that pitch down and you'd know you're not getting out of that
motherfucker because they put insane amount of reps into it.
And so even though the movement may look similar to someone who's not educated
in it,
when you're watching it,
if you know,
like a guy who really closes off something really good,
you go,
oh shit.
Like,
like Marcello Garcia.
If you were watching them roll with his gay teen,
I didn't know anybody could close off again,
taking that quick until I saw him do it like you're riot faber has on Nassy Gat,
so it's been a veto as all you guys at team Alpha male have sicky teens.
It's like you're known for it but there's like a 16th of a second quicker that
Marcella was slap it on than anybody.
You know what I mean?
Where it's like you recognize like Uriah has a worldclass guillotine and that
that shit is,
it's like vice grip but like you watch him do and you watch Marcello and he's
like,
oh he's on another level,
but this is one of the fucker's got a like a 16th of a second quicker closure or
something like that.
There's like just,
just a little bit of it,
lock it up.
Like he,
he taps guides and I'd never see good tab.
Like we're talking about aspirin.
There's a fantastic video of Marcello rolling with aspirin and just manhandling
them.
Just tapping and tapping and tapping and tapping them.
Like he would tap,
you know,
like anybody.
And it's crazy when you know how good a wrestler aspirin is.
There's so many weird levels to this.
That's the thing,
especially with this level of athletes in the UFC,
we're dealing split seconds and fractions of an inch,
you know,
like shit's got to be perfect but perfect.
It's just making,
having you land that striking that could hit you hit and don't get hit.
We're good,
you know,
but we're dealing split fucking seconds.
So that's just the way it's got to be.
What a crazy,
exciting job you act
like,
you know,
going from,
I've been,
you know,
training full board since I was 15 I'm 35 so it's been 20 years,
career.
But I've been training people it since I was 19 anyway.
And I've always understood the game,
kind of broke it down as I,
it's been self taught a lot.
Although like Trevor Whitman went,
boxing coach showed me a lot.
Bas Rutten,
he's been my main contributor to my arts as well.
And then I've trended on Mike Winkeljohn and Greg Jackson to cross paths with
million.
You know a lot of people,
Japan,
Thailand,
Holland,
right turn,
Ramon Dekkers for two weeks and I cross paths with a lot of people.
But a lot of my stuff is just self taught from DVDs and Youtube and the
Internet.
So I've been able to break things down my stuff because I had to learn it
myself.
And then teaching people,
like I took,
I took the pads game and Trevor Whitman until I'm like,
this is,
I know how to hold pads for me.
This is what it needs you to look out for.
So I taught him to train me.
So because of that and that he's,
he's an artist,
the guy can draw.
He just very detailed,
very analytical.
So that transferred back over to me.
So we were just a good relationship.
And then I had another guy,
Christian Allen,
and that guy is the best met hoarder I've ever seen,
ever worked with.
That guy can hold some fricking miss and he is a Ninja.
If he had,
if he believed in himself a bit more,
he could be the UFC champion 100% it's just some guys just have it physically,
just not so much mentally.
And that's a good thing here too.
My phone.
These guys are all world class athletes.
The wrestling mentality,
I don't have to babysit anybody.
Do they come in?
They put in the Rick that putting in the work,
the quality reps,
they help each other because Tony today we,
we're drilling,
you know,
we're building the counter,
I looking for the openings before,
during and after there's openings.
Where are they at?
Let's register them.
They see the idiosyncrasies.
What are they doing?
They're nervous.
What does their position?
It's one,
keep them get positioned.
So they're just a bunch of little small things.
It's not,
it's nothing.
No magic pill.
Just simple basic stuff.
Reiterating a million times correctly from the get go.
So that's one thing I've learned from boss,
from Trevor Women,
from all my travels is to break things down cause I'm not a super athletic guy.
So I've had to learn things from tentacle aspect and breaking them down.
So that they've worked for,
he said,
Take Eddie Bravo story.
Say he's not,
you know,
a great athlete so you can kind of break things down.
But that's another thing too with Jujitsu and Thai boxing you just do is slower.
It's a slower pace thing.
And then also the mental aspect,
you know,
you're not,
I can punch in the face,
you can relax a little bit.
You know,
if you get caught an armbar triangle,
you're going to tap,
you have more seconds to respond.
You know,
you're not going to die in striking.
People still freak out.
People don't like to get punched.
I don't like to get punched in the face,
but it takes a certain human being to go ahead and relax it.
But that composure,
so I can take a guy and a technique or a jor combination and then he could spar
with it.
Well,
how about between the,
the myths and the sparring that that's a pretty big gap.
How are we going to do with that gap?
We're going to do this drill with a little bit of sparring.
Okay,
now you can punch,
but uh,
you can't kick things like that.
Would it break it down into pieces.
We're adding a little bit of heat to the flame,
you know,
little bit more slower and slower.
And that's what these guys have great fucking technique and great control is
nothing.
Why wrestling get,
you know,
people get so good at resting cause they can relax,
they can relax that I can punch in the face.
Well let's not punch him in the face so hard.
So I have a million drills for these guys to work with and it's just,
it's simple,
easy,
basic stuff man.
I just,
and again,
I love my job and the add kicks in and I jumped around a conversation.
So it's a,
it's good magic.
Those donor stand,
what you're talking about as far as Mitt work,
what meant work is,
is when a guy holds the pads for you and you get the pads correct.
And uh,
there's all a lot to it.
There's a lot to getting a guy to do it correctly.
There's a lot to getting a guy that does it in,
you know,
like making you throw combinations that are like realistic combinations at work.
Good or work with you.
A guy who can take power shots to the arms cause you know when you're kicking
the shit out of a fucking pads guys get bad elbows.
I mean after awhile ago you have be strong as shit.
That's what the,
I had two is the hyperflex is from uh,
just being relaxed and receiving kicks in.
I have my elbows just come back to far and that I cross body and half card.
You know,
how am I on my arm?
Just going to switch my last few fights I couldn't spark cause if a punch came
and hyperflex mobiles they would just swell up and it would just hurt like the
timing and things like it would just slip the demission cause I'm not actually
doing the live drilling,
the life sparring.
So things just kind of doing what the way in my few last few fights and just
wasn't able to perform to the way I want it to.
Plus,
like the passionate sash wasn't really there for fighting,
so it's just perfect timing and you know,
blessed the knee and you know,
you're,
I had text me,
you want to come train us.
And it was a situation where you just done it for so long.
I don't have the enthusiasm for this anymore.
You still have the enthusiasm for the creative aspect of developing a fighter.
Yeah.
I love,
I'm a martial arts.
This is what I've done my whole life.
I love it.
I love living through these guys now.
It's just,
it's a rebirth for me.
it's,
I'm loving my life,
embracing it too.
I think it's really cool when a fighter or find something that he can do that's
equally exciting like right after their careers because that's always been
traditionally I'll real problem for all sorts of professional fighters,
whether it's boxers or MMA fighters.
There's always been those stories of guys who like live this crazy high life and
then afterwards like do you know how many boxers get hooked on cocaine?
No,
it's a lot,
man.
It's a fucking lot.
I'm obviously,
they're partying and obviously,
you know,
a lot of these guys are coming from lower income backgrounds,
so when all of a sudden they're making millions of millions of dollars,
they did tend to get a little crazy.
But the after effects of,
of like losing all that excitement,
like it's gone from your life.
Like there's very few guys that will transfer from that into becoming like
really good trainers.
Yeah,
that's a different scenario than me.
I don't,
I've never made millions of dollars and I sold drive a fucking 2006 scion xb
with windshield on a hole in the seat.
You know,
I never made $1 million in the last few fights.
I was contract the FC,
it was like 15 and 15 you know,
so it was making,
I didn't win the last couple fights,
so I walked away.
We don't have to sponsors like 20 grand and then,
you know,
pat my percentages.
So I had never made good money.
I've never broken six figures.
So it's a different scenario.
But that's,
I'm going to have the passion and I could live to these guys,
you know,
in the cage and just watching them and,
having them when it makes me feel like,
excuse me,
he's still relevant in life,
even mean necessarily the,
I mean,
part of it was the,
their success making the money,
but it was also just,
uh,
you know,
they're wild dudes.
And then once they lose that ability to get that crazy fix every few months
from,
uh,
a fight,
it's,
it's really hard for a fighter to find something that they can throw their
passion into that makes them feel like their life is still,
you know,
there's still like living their lives in the hills.
That's what I think about Duane duty a,
he'll be a passion about anything.
I don't care if it's walking down the street,
he's going gonna be the best at it.
He's,
do you hear,
um,
Mike,
uh,
passenger air from Mike's gym when he was talking about my training?
Uh,
Allister,
Allister Overeem.
One of the things he said that I thought it was really interesting and like the,
the pre fight a,
you know,
ream,
he does those documentaries,
those are sweet.
They're bad ass.
Whoever does those are an artist.
The music's great scenes are really artistically scene.
But Bet Mike said,
you know,
champion and he say fuck champion.
No matter what he does when he's tying his shoes,
he's a champion.
He's champion.
When he gets out of bed,
he's a jumping in when he brushed his teeth.
But exactly.
It's right.
You know,
like that mentality,
like t to really hit the highest levels of something,
you know,
you have to be like,
that's,
that's all you accept or not alive.
That's I am.
I'm very black and white.
I tried to do anything.
I don't try.
I do everything to my full potential with whatever I do.
It's just the way I'm wired.
It's how I've been at ever wasn't really taught.
This is just how I am so know who to think.
I guess our creator who are May,
whatever it is.
But I mean,
I love everything that I do.
It's good times,
man.
Well,
it's also you,
you've become successful as a martial artist and you,
you were very successful as a kickboxer and very successful as an MMA fighter.
So you know,
after all these years of competition,
exactly what fighters are going through,
you know,
you know what I mean?
You're not guessing it.
You're not in like,
you know like putting together game plans based on intelligence decisions but,
but you haven't been there yourself.
You've got both going on.
Yeah.
That's what I think helps to hear it too off most of these guys,
they know I've done it.
They and they know I'm passionate.
I'm there for these motherfuckers like hundred percent.
I watch film like a mother fucker.
I make sure that I went to Duquesne plants or do drills in the class.
It's for this specific a specific guys.
We have no class at 2030 people.
I make sure in our hour and a half class,
you know,
four or five rounds is for this guy for five rounds of this for this guy.
And to make sure that I gained plan planet,
tailor things.
And then also we do our private lessons is specifically for their fight based on
what they're already good at.
Cause they say,
okay Tj as good at,
you know,
these 10 things,
his opponent's grip,
these 10 things we've gotta be aware of these.
Okay,
five of t J's things going to work perfect for this guy.
Well let's draw the fuck out of those five things.
So that's one of the things too.
Like for me specifically when Bas Rutten would give me information or a
technique or cowboy had told me to do something,
I took it to heart 100% just like the Goulay fight I went to that fight with my
left shoulder is blown out.
So only thing I had was my right hand.
So that's why it kind of worked out for my favor.
That's the fossils,
the fast enough count.
Yeah.
And UFC.
So it just,
just the story behind it.
It was just a two week notice.
File wasn't training at all.
She's up in the mountains doing electrical work.
My mantra call me spin and he's like,
Hey,
you want to do a fight?
And I was like,
yeah,
sure,
what are they paying for?
And Four.
And I was like,
fuck man,
that's like a,
you know,
two months with the work,
let's go do the fight.
So I flew out and trip boss and it was actually trapped to tip plat bomb squad.
They would bomb squad,
you know,
and I was just want to take down a fence and Connor human,
actually I got double end hooks on a shot and he took me over his back and blew
out my left shoulder.
So I'm all,
I could draw all the keys up,
dropped kicks and knees still,
but just as the right hand.
So it's all I was looking for.
And the boss was like,
okay,
he's going to come in and just took off to the side right hand.
I was like,
okay,
cool.
Dang.
Bell comes to boom.
And I'm like,
Holy Shit.
Did you see that?
And it goes up,
there's a photo,
there's a funnel.
Like I'm punching him and he's looking away and I'm like looking at boss,
not looking at Boston.
I'm looking off to the side just because it happened so fast.
But I mean there's,
there's two things to that too.
I don't think you like took the best punch and I can hit hard.
So it was a couple of things to that and then it was go and I,
Jordan and Lillian,
do you have any regrets?
Like when you look back on your career?
Yeah,
I definitely have regrets.
My dream from a child was to be not from Charlie.
I guess when I was 1516 I was first start time boxing was to fight for k one be
the heavyweight champion to k one and I never grew that big.
So then,
and then the student Thai boxing,
jumping back and forth to an Mua and Thai boxing cause just have boxing,
you can't stay busy in America.
He couldn't anyway.
And then k one created the Max,
the midway or you know,
70 kilos,
one 54 and then actually have it on the table.
Same time was a Cuban contract and UFC contract after I fought gangs,
that was actually one fight deal.
And they offered me a three fight deal.
And then Kate went off for me to deal as well.
Marjorie was always go to k one and I went to k one just cause that was my
childhood passion.
But looking back on it now,
I wish I would have to stay with the UFC from the get go.
But you know,
just being stuck in my ways and wanting to do k one and go visit Japan.
It was just one of those things.
But going back,
I wish it would have rolled and Russell Moore and then just definitely stayed in
the UFC.
I do making more money now.
I'd be more well off.
It probably wouldn't be having an autistic PSI on and I'd probably own a house
right now.
So,
but on the flip side of that as well,
you know,
if I did own a house I could rent that of course.
Um,
I probably wouldn't have taken the job here at team Alpha male and live it to
these guys.
So it's,
you know,
I learned the hard lesson of being a 10 99 subcontractor employee and I blew my
knee out and had like three months with their pay in a year long injury.
So I'm like,
fuck,
you know,
I was,
I kind of figured out what am I going to do?
And then you're,
I had just texts me,
he's like,
hey,
you want to come out and you know,
be our head trainer.
And I was like,
look at that and let's try it one more surgery to go through.
And I'm like,
fuck man.
Yeah.
Hey am I am I start with Jay Mills.
The first 10 seconds he did an outside trip and blew my knee out like the first
10 seconds of the fight.
So ACL was completely gone and a bucket handle tear of the meniscus.
So if that was gone,
so like I'm actually still not 100% healed.
Well I suppose to be hundred percent in a year and,
and it's almost a year now.
So it may be,
it's happening but still swells up.
So I'm not even training or anything.
I just started holding mitts for these guys about two months ago.
So you got a patellar tendon graft,
right?
I,
yeah,
he's my patella tendon.
Yeah.
Tell by the scar.
I've had both of those done.
The regular,
the cadaver one and the battalion.
Oof.
I was statistically speaking,
you're supposed to use your own body parts to the lower percentage of rejection.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of different minds.
Great.
But there's a bunch of different schools of thought on that.
I wonder if it's,
you know,
the quality of the doctor.
I don't,
I'm not smart enough or educated enough about medicine to make a real comment
about that.
But for me,
um,
they're both great.
They both work right?
There was no problems.
I had meniscus taken out of the left knee.
That's the only difference.
It's a little,
do you run much though?
No,
no I don't.
I do elliptical machines.
I like to do sprints on elliptical machines.
Like put out,
let's crank it up really heavy.
Like put it on like,
you know,
depending on whatever it is like,
like right below the,
the highest level and to just do 30 minute wild man sprints.
Like that's what I do.
Or 30 seconds around wild man sprints.
That's what I do.
It give him a hotel room and I can't,
you know,
if there's not a gym there to just have one of those elliptical machines,
you can still get a bad work as a kill your legs man.
Just gotta go nutty with it.
I just do it like fucking dragons chasten me 30 seconds and then I take 30
seconds of just breathe and all.
I'm moving but I'm just breathing and then wow,
I just warm up for 10 minutes and then do that hotels or wherever you're at.
And then people are just looking and you're like,
what the hell's this guy doing?
He's like,
it's just an elliptical man.
Chill out.
You're watching training for a fight.
Just yelling on the machine or sprinting as hard as you can on the treadmill.
You know,
he makes me shy when we go work.
Cause that guy I like,
I'm like if somebody
is having sex next,
that's what it's gotta do.
You gotta go gotta do it.
I'm not even preparing for anything.
I was just scared.
There's a lot of lines.
I'm scared like dragons chasing.
Yeah.
Fuck it.
If I'm lifting weights I'm lifting like I might die if I don't get this weight
up,
I'm going to die.
Different mentality though,
guys know,
you know they're literally putting their last one line when there is a
possibility of course,
cause it's a possibility you can hit by cars across the street as well.
But credibly dates just one of those things.
But I,
you know,
I love it man.
It's say,
you know,
I loved it when I was fighting.
You know,
passion is trying to kind of dwindling away.
So it's just perfect timing.
Like you know,
things work out for you.
What happened for a reason,
whatever.
I'm learning to believe and understand that this the my own path of my own
career.
Although I know there are some things that you know,
whatever you believe and conceive you can achieve kind of thing.
So that kind of thing.
I think that's 100 fucking percent true.
I feel so
well it certainly is.
It certainly is with me.
I always wonder when,
what the fuck is really going on with that?
Whether or not you just got lucky and you're just looking back on being lucky
gone.
Well,
you know,
it's just uh,
the,
the world works out for itself.
Does it really work out for itself or does it,
is it just you capitalize on whatever the fuck you,
you balance yourself out and you get through it no matter what.
It's not that everything happens for a reason.
It's just that if you have the correct attitude and you don't get hung up on
things,
you can succeed.
You just keep pushing forward.
You find your opportunities eventually and you jump through him.
I mean,
who's to say that opportunities couldn't have come up that were even better a
year ago or 10 years ago or five years ago?
They could have,
but when they,
it's a matter of when they do or when you create them capitalize.
Yes.
So you were in the perfect position to do that.
Like it was perfect.
It was a good Gig,
you know,
so it's,
it's smart to jump on it and perfect for you.
Yeah.
For me,
you know,
spiritually and anything just living through these guys now it's another rebirth
and I am the crack guy for this job.
Make we're were vibe and fucking a hundred percent perfect man.
It's awesome.
It's a great mix with these guys.
They have no problem John.
I don't have to babysit these motherfuckers.
They show up on time,
they show respect that they're to get better.
They help you with any help each other.
Even when they don't have fights coming up,
they still come in and help the train partner cause I'm like okay look today you
need to be this guy.
Can you need to be cleaned?
Waited for for 10 minutes and then he'll mimic like Whitney and watch the film
and come in and he'll dance around and do his thing.
Just to give us to look for our next step.
Right.
That's the way it's gotta be.
That's so important.
I don't have 100%.
I don't really have training camps and you're,
you know,
I have to get help.
I've been training for the last two months helping,
you know,
you're,
I get ready.
Chad's fighting next week and Josias fight in September 4th Danny just fought a
in Seattle,
you know,
so I've been helping everyone get ready.
I've been in shape for the last,
who knows how long,
you know,
and so I'm always ready to take a fight as long as I'm not an injured.
So crazy young man there.
Yeah.
That's why I worked out good for his last fight.
You know,
he was turning,
I was fine with Hugo Vianna.
Yeah.
Was that's too,
yeah,
that's right.
His last two fights were showing those fights,
but he's always training.
Oh,
he's insurance so it doesn't matter.
Yeah,
that's a,
it's a,
you guys have a really cool camp.
And one of the things that's really important is that what you said about that
wrestler mentality.
There's like when they were trying to take wrestling out of the Olympics,
there was so many people were really frustrated and really angry and people
never wrestled.
Don't understand this.
I only wrestled for one season.
Solando I'm just talking out of my ass,
but I know what it did for me and just in one season.
Yeah,
I remember working.
I remember doing that one season of wrestling and thinking,
that's probably the hardest I've ever worked at anything in my fucking life for
sure.
And I had done martial arts from a much earlier than that I had,
I'd been involved in physical things.
I played sports,
but I was like this,
I played soccer.
I'm like,
this is the nuttiest most soul crushing shit when you're exhausted and then make
you fucking doing sprints,
carrying guys on your back and you're just nutty Shit,
man.
Down and go,
motherfucker.
I'm like running stairs.
And they broke you.
You would show up every day.
Everything in your body would be fucking sore.
But if you can get through that,
it'll make you an incredibly strong persa and that's the advantage that the
wrestler mentality has.
Like I always say that the,
if the pyramid of mixed martial arts techniques was ever established,
in my opinion,
at least wrestling is the base group.
And it's not just because of the,
the actual ability to control where the fight takes place,
where they're standing up or to take it to the ground and whether you're using
it chocolate,
Dell style or whether you're,
you know,
Ben Aspirin in it though,
the most important aspect of it is the mentality that comes with that training.
It's not like Jujitsu.
It's not like kickboxing and nobody else works at heart.
We,
when we weigh in every week,
we,
we compete every weekend and you're always hungry.
Oh,
always.
You have to be,
you know what I mean?
If you're not,
you're getting beat,
you're not going to be the best in the world,
you know?
Yeah.
You have to be,
you have to have the mentality of,
you know,
pushing harder than that next guy in that sport because it's just a one on one
muscle versus muscle.
Like,
you know,
it's,
it's tough.
I think the weight cutting aspect of it is a huge tragedy.
In high school though.
I really,
really do.
I have a friend,
um,
who was a really good wrestler in high school and uh,
he tried to stay at one 28 through his entire career and he was a fucking Zombie
and his senior year,
the kid always had bad breath because the mouth is always wide open.
He looked like a Zombie and he was,
he was five,
six,
all of his brothers,
six feet tall or taller than his girlfriend.
He just fucking crushed himself.
He ruined his body wrestling.
That was me at 55,
man,
I'll just kill myself.
I didn't know how to cut weight.
Right?
I was just always running Abilene on rubber suit running and just like trending
Thai style,
just running a lot and just killing my body.
So I think not,
I don't think I definitely fucking,
no 100% that killed me.
That coastal,
my passion as well,
and then was able to receive punches as well,
either just draining my body,
hydrate it correctly.
So I just didn't understand the game until I got what Mike Dolce and I,
motherfucker,
he's got his shit down.
He definitely knows how to make the human body lose weight correctly and then
come back also.
But it's all a journey.
I've learned a lot to lessen that.
I find out,
I know exactly what the fuck do I lead with is now.
That's for sure.
And that's what wrestling or anything and he,
you know,
you know what he's capable of and definitely know exactly what the fuck I'm
comfortable.
Yeah.
You know your limitations.
I mean there comes a point in time when you literally can go no further.
You can take no steps.
You can lift your body up,
you're done.
Can you get there though?
Do you get there or do you decide that 10 steps before that was there?
Because that could be the difference to a fight and losing it
for,
right.
The difference between being able to keep those rpms up just a little while
longer than the next guy.
And that's what wrestling teaches you because there's wrestling is a,
is a strange martial art in that,
you know,
you look at a guy like aspirin who is not like the physically the most like
Kevin Randleman [inaudible] physically impressive fighter I think I've ever
seen.
And he's just a super alpha male mesomorphic build.
But you look at Ben,
ask her and you don't see that.
But if you,
if you said like,
who's the better recipes?
Well,
didn't back better dynamic athlete is Kevin Randleman for sure.
But man,
as far as wrestling accomplishments,
Ben aspirins more accomplished.
And that's pretty incredible because in wrestling you engage,
there's going to be an engaging and if you don't engage,
you're going to lose points for it.
And so you're going to tie up and you're gonna find out what the fuck is up.
Once you do that.
And there's a,
there's a difference in that.
And in the fact that it's going to go down.
Whereas like kickboxing man,
there's,
we've all seen bouts where almost nothing happens.
There's a lot of fucking move and they both decided to coast that shit
can happen in the brain.
Then you talking about like boring fights and such.
How about when a,
what was it?
The dance [inaudible] you liked that one Mr Rogan?
Where are you at?
No,
that one I was like,
yeah,
but I think through that
look I would have hated to watch it but I think we had to go through it as,
as martial arts,
like as a,
as a martial art,
like which mixed martial arts is essentially,
I mean is it,
is the sport most realistic to fighting?
And I think we had to know that that can happen at these two fucking guys can
just circle each other going do nothing.
I mean we have to know,
we've seen a bunch of fights like that.
So then that's when instead of encouraging the standup,
you encourage like a shot.
Motherfuckers don't encourage shit man.
Say,
if a guy like Craig,
we'd can run away from gray Maynard for three rounds then so be it.
So he can,
you know,
look,
I get it.
I know what you're saying.
You would like him to try to win,
but he's not gonna.
Yeah.
Okay.
So that's possible too.
So here,
here's the guy just decides to stay alive.
Okay.
He's not trying to win the fight.
There's nothing wrong with that.
I mean I think there is,
there is in watching it,
I don't want to watch it,
but then the market will dictate whether you watched that guy again.
You know,
if you're going to watch a guy like Michael Chandler is a good example.
A lot of guys don't know who he is and he's one of the best one 55 hours in the
world and he's a fucking animal.
He's awesome.
He comes after afternoons.
And so when you get a guy like that or a,
you know,
a guy like Melvin Manhoef as a kickboxer,
you'd get these wild Berzerker dudes.
You met Vandelay Silva you want to watch.
And so they're worth more money and you know,
and they were going to get booked more and they're going to get higher plate.
I mean,
people are gonna want to see that shit.
So I think that when,
if you have a boring style,
you ultimately pay for it in your career.
And that's how it should be.
The market,
I think should dictate,
you know,
how how you do with that style.
But if you're a dude,
like if Ben Looks,
let's say Ben asking gets to the UFC,
okay.
Which is entirely possible.
Now I,
he's a free agent
and he just mugs,
GSP.
Yeah.
Just gets all the GSP and just sticks his fucking chest on its face for five
rounds and,
and punches him in the head to,
I believe he could do it.
He might look what?
But what if he does then what the fuck do we do?
What if he can do that day?
Everybody?
What if Ben bad her and just monkey fucks everybody.
And every middle weight fight from here on out is,
is like in a lot of fans,
size is,
is uneventful and boring.
Guess what?
That shit's real.
Somebody has to figure it out.
Stuff to take down.
Somebody has to figure out how to either hit him coming in or you got a Marcella
Garcia,
you got to get someone who's so high level on the ground that he can't stay in
this position.
That's when it comes,
you know you're watching the film and he say,
okay he does this.
So when he does that,
I'm going to make him do that.
By me doing this,
you take the what if game.
What if games,
I don't want to give away any game plants case any your boys fight him.
But without specific for any particular fighter.
If someone was gonna Fight Ben,
ask her.
And how would you talk about some films?
I don't even watch them to be honest.
I'd have to say.
Okay.
How about fish?
I know you watched it.
I've watched fit fitches similar watching a lot of ways I'd have to watch a film
with the mindset of coaching against him because there's a difference.
Cause I watch film and I'll,
I'll take a film and it depends because sometime I can watch her,
I just go off memory.
I already know how to beat the guy or how I feel like he can beat the guy,
you know.
So I get crazy with fucking watching film and so I'll take a film.
I used to,
anyway,
I just take a film,
watch it sober,
boom.
I used to take it and watch it high just to give me an honest approach because I
am very biased and I come there,
I'm there for my fucking guy's 100% so all I saw,
I noticed that I'll watch fights.
I'm like,
fuck man,
I know my guys to do this,
this,
and I realize I'm not watching this with the honest,
open mind.
So,
and then I watch it on Alpha brain as well on it,
round for brain just to get different looks on things.
I have another guy in Colorado,
Mike Tempo,
who watched it,
the fights,
asked the fighters to watch the fights.
I get a whole bunch of film,
I'll make notes,
compare the notes,
see what we need to work with.
But some guys I can just watch the film and break it down.
No right off the bat.
But I'd have to watch Fitch to answer your question with the Crick Mindset of me
being coaching,
it's like me right now.
Like I'm hyped up and again like the Roman God,
this is fucking awesome for me.
Like I love this shit.
I've learned so much from the Rogan podcasts and from you and your guests,
you know like Mike Dolce,
Alex Grey,
Graham Hancock,
you [inaudible] like,
you know Joey Coco Diaz,
like a lot of guys have been on here.
Man,
I fucking,
I've learned more from this fucking podcast and it had,
you know,
in school or my life trials for sure 100%.
So this has done a lot for me,
for me.
So for me to be on this manic,
it's fucking cool.
And it's food stuff like,
um,
you know,
like I'm still relevant.
I'm doing things in life like Yo,
like boss written stories on here,
you know like Boston back man.
I love that guy.
So where's my black belt?
Boston.
Was it that much?
No,
no.
Listen to podcasts.
Mr [inaudible] keep interrupting me.
Oh yeah,
good,
good.
Carry on.
I have as well,
like it's not a one way street,
but having these conversations with people like you and you know,
I mean being able to pick people's brains,
being able to,
well it's these exchanges,
that energy.
Yeah.
The exchange is like,
what's a cool fucking journey for me,
it's for me to like create a combo or a technique,
you know,
and show it to somebody.
You're going have them drill.
It brought up this point and then when the fucking fight with that same exact
technique,
that shit is fucking nuts.
That's who,
that's fucking cool man.
You know what's really cool about it?
It's like really is artistic and so like everything is an art and especially
considering the fact that there's really no established protocol to do it like
this,
everybody has their own way.
If you went to Greg Jackson,
he would have one method to train a fighter and you went to Matt Hume.
He would have a different way of training a fighter.
That's why I think I've trained it.
Greg,
I haven't tried my have shown great.
He's got great stuff.
He's awesome stuff.
That's again,
I'm making sure I'm adjusting to the athlete.
I'm not trying to,
you know,
make them me.
I'm trying to,
you know,
just like Chai Mendez,
he hits me at Spi does certain things a certain way.
Tj does things a certain way.
I need to adjust to these guys.
I need to give them my ideas and my opinions might my,
my little bits of information while they're doing what they feel comfortable
doing.
Because if you can pull that off,
what I would feel technically incorrect.
But if you can make that work,
you can make that work.
What the fuck can I say?
I can't argue with success.
If you're landing there.
My hand on that Hook,
I mean,
I'd say,
you know,
you're lunging in your heater Chin's up.
You know,
you're,
you're out of position,
you're making it work.
You're making it work.
But how about let's keep our position.
How about let's set that up a different note.
Another way you can just give it another look at things.
So to answer the question,
as far as I encourage my guys to get other pieces of information,
know go,
go train over there,
go get different looks.
I want to bring people in.
I wanna start working,
hopefully Boston coming to [inaudible] and do a seminar.
I'm hoping to bring leaster Boeing doesn't take away your value.
It adds to interrupted me.
Yeah.
But then I hung up on our conversation so I told us,
I just,
I just love it man.
I definitely want to have as much input cause I don't want it to be,
you know,
stubborn and set in my ways when making these guys do one thing.
I want these guys to be the best martial arts that can be.
So does that means being the other guys?
I mean it's visiting other James Man and fucking do it.
So I know I'm not here for me.
I'm here for these fucking guys.
So I just want to go to Spain.
You have to bring in other people?
I think so 100% and isn't that,
that was a real problem with some trainers,
some and worried about other people coming in and we're going to take their
thunder.
You know what was really cool?
So I was just,
sorry,
I was just in Boston for a year.
I his fight and Marcela grotty hand me out for a seminar and there's open doors.
Then we cheat just to instant and it's the way,
you know his energy and shit.
Man,
that was fucking awesome.
He's a true martial artist man.
I love that dude.
He's very,
very fucking cool.
And,
and he,
uh,
he did a technique of the week video just like you did as well for my bank and
we tie series.
So you know that,
that was awesome.
I got a great group of people around me like Mr Rogan and you know,
the team Alpha male and my art design guy.
Aaron,
you're earning Colorado.
And,
um,
my,
my highlight guy,
James Blair who just do my recent,
my new highlight with the team,
like that mother Fucker,
he can,
he can edit some fucking video.
And what's the name of that?
If people want to find out,
pull that shit up.
Cause this is this newest one and these are the latest uploader.
Second to pull it on my youtube channel being with youtube channel,
but I just made it a,
uh,
a video and a heart attack.
I mean two fl,
two to do three things.
We're in Sacramento to do three things,
take care of my family and I get these motherfuckers world titles.
And then to push my bank with Thai brand cause I'm,
you know,
I need to take my art information and monetize it.
I need to make money off that now.
I mean I ain't making no fucking money.
I couldn't be 100%.
I'm not,
I'm not rich man.
Like for real,
I'm about,
I'm trying to be real.
I want to own a house,
I want to have my shit paid off.
I want to,
you know,
live a comfortable life.
My family.
And I am not going to be the martial artists who's not gonna make it any mother
fucking money.
Right.
Well,
yeah,
I know too much not become successful is that they become successful and then
it'll,
you know,
took it down to me,
which is cool.
If they become,
they are.
These motherfuckers are very,
see that's the thing too.
Like before I came,
look how successful they've been without me.
Like I'm not trying to change.
I'm going to try and tighten them up.
We're not trying like I'm fucking doing that.
I'm tightening them up.
It is because they're listening to me and just because they know I'm there for
them.
So there's a couple layers to this onion of why of our success is not just me.
It's their belief in me as well.
It's why I carry myself is the way they carry themselves and I'm adapting to
them.
They're trying to make them Duane Ludwig,
I making them the best martial arts that can help them be.
Is there a danger of keeping the name Alpha male?
Has it hit the radical douche point yet?
I'm not sure.
I worry about,
I worry about the Alpha brain.
I'm like man,
you know it's it bros out at bros out at about a team.
The Bang would tie a smash.
I know,
he know.
I feel like I feel like fucking splinter from the Ninja turtles and like these
are my Ninja Turtles.
Just like,
cause like in San Hosea on the April 20th is rolled in and had that fucking Tj
Dillashaw Benevides and Mendez.
I'll just come and just smashed her post and just leave.
It was like we just wrote it to the town smashed him and the belts.
That was the fucking coolest shit ever.
I wish people could experience that same,
that same energy that does all that.
It's just fucking cool man above it.
Your absolute limit shit.
I fucking love him.
Like real technical improvement.
He taught you brought up Chad Mendez before.
God Damn is that due to fucking athlete.
He is on another level how Mike Tyson stuck out in the boxing world.
This is Chad Mendez.
He is this successful are very,
very dynamic.
Um,
if we can just super athletic athletes.
I know he lost to Aldo,
but I believe that was before you guys started working together,
right?
Correct.
Yeah.
I've seen big leaps.
I just came to the team in January is when I move out of their general,
not one of those freaky abilities to cover distance with punches is an explosive
fast.
He's fast.
He's on another level.
100%.
That's the same thing when I was talking about Marcello,
like finishing up gay teens.
Yeah.
Got It.
There's guys like Mendez.
It hit takedowns.
I hit doubles and you're like,
Jesus Christ,
his,
his take down as a missile,
it's impossible to stop.
That's what's so crazy about Aldo,
that all those stuff,
I think,
I think Chad gave them to introspect.
You know what I mean?
I think Chad just fed,
gave him too much respect on some stuff too,
though.
They mean you have to give him respect,
but not to the point where it's hindering your own ability.
That's the thing I do when I felt Ramon Dekkers,
you know,
like,
I mean you can't,
I mean,
you got to give her home decors all the respect in the world.
I looked up to nudge one of the greatest Moyie Thai fighters all time.
It's very arguable.
The greatest cause.
Yeah,
100%.
And I just didn't,
I just looked up to him too much and I just didn't perform to my full ability
and that was disrespectful to him.
I felt so lost.
You know,
that was one of the things too,
but you know,
I mean,
he socked me up and you know,
he won and he'd probably do it again,
but I just didn't perform to my full potential.
But I mean,
he'd probably beat my ass no matter what,
man.
I love that dude here.
And in all fairness,
she also fought him.
He was pretty late in his career,
right?
Yeah.
Late in his career.
And he still talks to me about bullshit.
Dammit.
Yeah,
he's good man.
I'm one of the fucker.
I got man,
much respect for that guy.
He has bad ankles now.
Something we passed now.
He died recently.
Bike riding.
I you had a heart attack.
So yeah.
Fucking crazy.
Yeah,
but he used to have really bad ankles.
Right?
Like you had like towards the end,
just from speaking elbows.
I mean he hit,
he hit too hard for his,
his weight and his body.
You know,
like the guy was a powerhouse meals.
The doors that the,
the,
the Dutch windmill or something,
I forgot his,
you know,
one of his,
one of his nicknames.
But Ramon Dekkers as bad ass.
We found one of the videos but we couldn't,
when we went to the youtube page,
we,
it didn't exist.
Just look up.
Bang.
Moitai highlight.
I'll find it in three seconds.
Here's up here.
Google.
Here's the type punch slip,
drill.
No,
that's not it.
And Bang,
boy,
ty highlight.
Okay.
With tight team Alpha male highlight.
I bet you don't even have to write that.
Yeah,
you do actually bang.
Moitai highlight a Alpha male highlight.
Yeah,
that's it.
Go to Bang Moy,
Tai highlight.
Choose the third one down.
It says bang more time team Alpha male.
Put it up so we could see it.
Okay.
You fucked up Brian.
Now when we had the TVS off,
it turns off the display monitor,
so,
oh,
okay.
So here we go.
Back on.
Hold on.
Anyway,
powerful incident anywhere.
What a cool motherfucker.
We did like a one o'clock in the morning and I heard that.
I listen to all kinds of podcasts,
man.
I love this guy.
He's cool.
So that was so cool.
It was like him and chuck just sitting here chatting.
That's gotta be cool,
man.
Talking about the old days,
helping out with the Fukushima sash.
Man.
That's cool.
Yeah.
They said that.
Doesn't that seem like it's getting worse and worse?
They're starting to see a radiation and tuna.
Wow.
Showed elevated radiation.
3% elevation and radiation of tuna for the Kachin and California.
Yeah.
This is the highlight.
Put that show on full screen.
It's just highlighting chills,
man.
This just got done today.
Thank you,
James Blair.
I can fricking,
that's amazing.
And has some videos,
man.
He's been hooking me up for a long time.
He does all kinds of bad ass videos.
What the fuck is my lens?
You're going
to have such a technical stride.
You're like Twain luck.
Powerful promotion.
Your head coach and I'm filling for my pump my stuff man.
Or you know saying I'm promoting.
Sorry.
I think you,
I think that's the Rogan.
Thank you sir.
You're welcome.
Appreciate it.
Yeah.
Whoever edited this is fucking glare.
That guy's bad ass.
Oh,
he did an awesome job,
Ben,
to be taking everything we get is hey kid,
I wanted to ask you about that too.
Kicks to the back of the head.
Well,
well what?
Let this play out first.
Wait,
help me.
Fucking bad ass.
There's the next year.
See champion Benevidez a well,
it's physically get the shopper.
It's highly,
Mandy has a beat both of them there,
but I think it's gonna be chat.
It's closer to the title shot just for the rankings situation.
Benevidez is also getting better,
man.
Yeah.
Fucking
animal.
It's delish Dillashaw booth.
Where you at?
Oh,
I love that fight,
dude.
That was the first Friday where I said,
wow,
you just,
you hit another level.
You were clearly on an the level technically like the way you were moving.
Appreciate that cousin Leonard Garcia doing things correctly.
That kids are wild motherfucker.
So is this one?
Yeah.
Benevidez Tornado rings and shifts.
Tornado of punches,
man.
Dude.
Ways they wouldn't.
Nipple rings on.
He's a savage.
Oof.
Yeah.
That was great.
If
you were an animal,
this soundtrack sounds like you're walking through a door and your TV shows,
there's not enough screeching
wolf's calling.
What a wild highlight.
Helping my bandwidth high system.
What I do is I have a,
each week I sent out 20 affiliates.
I have four to 10 detailed veto curriculums showing them exactly what drill or
techniques to do that week and each week I take my phone.
That's,
that's what it is.
Like.
I'm not just trying to sell you a banner of my name and put on your gym.
I take my fucking iPhone,
like we recorded the video today.
I take my phone.
I said,
okay,
I have my curriculum,
I have my structure Crick them,
whatever we do this week we do that same class in three or six months from now,
depending on if it's the intermediate or fundamental curriculum.
By take my film,
my,
my phone,
I record the videos.
My mainly with Tj Dillashaw recorded like,
this is the drill that you do.
Boom,
here's life.
Boom.
Now you're going to do this drill five for five or one four rounded piece.
Depends on what it is and what we could just as well,
but I send them exactly what fucking droves and Columbus to do that week.
Each and every week.
I send that shit out and I'm very proud of that.
Come on.
I know too much not to teach them and I love it.
I wish I had this for me when I was coming up and I'm like,
I'm,
I just,
I love life now.
It's fucking,
it's fucking cool.
I have you on Adderall,
right?
No,
I'm on my [inaudible].
I got whatever.
What's this?
Coffee bulletproof and I took four Alpha brains battle.
Dude.
I'm telling you man,
like this is fucking,
I love the Po.
Good Times for Alpha brain.
I think you can get away with by far the way I was only joking about the Alpha
brain or how of a male thing.
You can get away with it because people call us death squad,
which is way do sheer right.
As long as you act cool man,
the name,
they'll be all right.
It's making your heart pound.
It's like we're trending like I'm passionate and I love that.
You didn't know.
I mean,
I fucking,
I love life man.
I love it.
I mean I have,
I kept through so much bullshit as a child to come.
I'm happy I could do what the fuck I wanted to do right now.
You know,
I love life,
man.
It's fucking cool.
I get to make the decisions that I want to fucking make as an adult now and
well,
most of the decisions anyway,
so it,
you know,
it's good man.
That's good.
I'm living through these guys.
You know,
they're going to get the fucking world title.
It's going to be Benevides.
Are Chad first upon who?
You know,
what shot we get first.
I'm a game plan the fuck out of that and,
but I'm going to get painted in there and makes sure that there I'm going to
have,
ask them to do what I feel they need to do for the fight.
I'm not trying to make them me.
I mean you're,
and you're just enjoying watching fucking boy this shit.
Yeah,
man.
Like I mean I'm learning to the point now that when I have a good time,
like this Rogan podcast where we train or I'm in the fights,
I'm learning to embrace that shit a hundred fucking percent as much as I can.
And then when I have a problem or a difficult time,
I'm stepping away and looking at that from the sites.
I didn't want to be wrapped up in the problems.
I want to look at the site at the problems from the distance and we have a good
time.
When I'm in that cage and I'm walking these guys out and I'm fucking holding
myths and all the podcasts.
I'm trying to enjoy this shit to the full potential I can cause I know I'm going
to be on this fucking earth for however,
however long I'm going to be.
Knock your shit off Tj.
I fucking,
I just,
I love this shit man.
I do like said I love it.
You're mad.
Like I love it man.
It's like,
well I want to make sure other motherfuckers love their life too.
So they need to make the decision that they needed to make fucking happy doing
something that people enjoy and doing something that you can,
you can help people with is one of the keys to happiness.
That's one of the things too.
I'm seeing these guys know,
get better human beings at martial artist that is making me feel good.
Why isn't it an interesting thing?
It's like being a fighter and being a training partner are two very different
things and then being a trainer or as another very different thing and a lot of
people don't understand that like to be a good training partner you have to,
first of all,
you have to know where a fighter is in the,
in their development unit that got,
I'm not taking advantage of them.
You got to not hit him when,
when you know they're fucking,
they're doing five fresh guys in a row.
Don't be a dick head.
Just make them work.
Make the guy work and that's what you're supposed to be doing.
I asked the guys at the gym,
I tell him,
you know,
I ask them,
you interrupted me now bitch.
Yes I did.
You ready to go?
What the hell?
It's beat him up there.
What I was going to start carry on.
I'm just kidding.
To carry on.
It's being trainers another,
that's the next thing.
It's a completely different thing and in that your benefiting entirely on other
people benefiting from you and you,
you take your pride in molding them as fighters,
you know?
Sure.
It's a very different experience though,
right?
It is different experience in it,
but it's something I've been doing since I 1990 way is just,
you know,
helping press athletes training.
There's this cause I need to train the partners.
I'm trying to get to know them.
What if I'm doing this,
you know,
look out for this and just helping people break things down,
help them to help coach me as well.
So it's been a give and take.
And now for me to do it full time man.
And again,
I'm not going to say it,
but I love it.
Are you,
are you,
do you think you're happier as a trainer then?
You were as a fighter as I was too stressed and I'm,
you know,
I understood,
um,
that,
you know,
when,
when the fight,
I'm going to make so much.
If I didn't want to fight,
I'm gonna make this much.
And that was,
that was a hard thing for me.
And I've,
I've reached my,
um,
like in 2004,
after I won my second world title,
I'll kickboxing though.
It was tough.
First of all,
the time.
It was MMA with chance.
And then my second world title was a tight box will title.
So once I made,
once I did that,
I completed the goals that I set in my life.
And then from there things changed.
We could look at that,
just the statistics and my record.
It was blah,
blah,
boom.
Maybe,
you know,
lost your tooth.
Baboom baboom kicking everybody's ass,
but doing good.
And then at 2004,
my one or my second world title,
it just went bump,
bump,
bump up.
You just lost your enthusiasm again.
Yep.
Was it just a matter of just not being able to keep up and needed our PM's or
was it the training environment?
Uh,
you know,
I'm not quite sure where to push the blame,
but the main thing for me to say blame,
well,
you know,
it's supposed to really look at it obviously right life.
But I just had a goal to win the world title,
kickboxing world title.
When I was a child,
my first world title is anyway,
we'll title.
I didn't complete my goal,
so I went for the world that kickbox won't title came around and I finally got
it.
So then that just changed things for me.
I should've said I set my goals too low.
Basically I think title,
did you have an MMA?
Uh,
when I fought Jens Pulver and UCC in the candidate when I'll just first,
I think his first fight and once he left he left the UFC.
That was a quick knockout to right.
Correct.
Yeah,
yeah.
That was,
yeah,
that was,
um,
when you were,
you know,
you were really super fucking sharp back then.
Really Super Sharp,
especially what you're striking.
Yep.
Correct.
Yeah.
Oh,
you know,
I was healthy,
I was enthusiastic and then you're good.
But when it went to one of my second world title,
you had to set my goals too low.
And then I started like searching for,
okay,
I need certain opponent to motivate me,
or I need a,
you know,
a certain train to get me.
I need to go train here.
Starts searching for things.
Maybe,
maybe Monday is going to motivate me and I started looking,
searching for things to motivate me because it was just,
I'm just very black and white and I'm going to win a world title.
I set my goal,
I went to,
I got this and I was Kinda like,
now what?
Do you ever stop and go,
damn,
I wish I had somebody like meet training me.
I say that 100% man.
That's why I tell these fucking guys to like,
you know,
I'm there coaching them like I'm there for them.
Like pay attention.
Like don't waste my fucking time.
Don't show up play.
Don't do,
don't do the drill.
Halfass we're doing split seconds and fractions of an inch.
It's got to be fucking done.
Right or don't fucking do it.
And there's more money in MMA now.
There's more money in a way now for sure.
Back when you were in king in the cage.
Yeah.
My first couple of my first two fights.
Can the kids,
you've got zero money.
Yeah,
the,
the king of the cage.
When,
when you pulled off the karate kid.
Oh.
Storytime.
All right,
here we go.
Range.
And so,
um,
it was uh,
you know,
I was nervous for the fight.
We'll still,
apparently the promoter told me that that fight or wanted to,
he asked to fight me.
So I took that personal,
let's go.
Okay.
Right.
Mother fucker.
He wanted to fight me.
So I'm backstage,
I'm a little know,
not little,
I'm nervous as fuck for the fight.
And so boss sees that I'm nervous and he wants me to relax.
He goes,
Hey Dwayne,
if you want throw him off,
do the credit kit.
And I'm like,
hey.
I'm like,
I look back at it now,
I see what he's trying to do to relax me.
But at the time when like fuck boss and I'm nervous as fuck him,
go find like,
you know,
knocking off.
So I got to the point of the fight where I was just talking him up.
I,
you know,
I had my wings,
I was doing what I wanted and then it just came to me just to kind of little
tribute to boss to do that.
You credit the kid and then,
then I went back to fighting and then they,
uh,
you know,
they stopped about,
but so,
you know,
I took that.
That's what my angel logo.
It was a couple pieces to that.
You know,
it's doing the credit kid as far as I,
it should be two boss.
It's got the wings because I feel like I always make the right decisions.
I don't screw people over.
Give an angel watching over.
You well know that it's just,
you know,
yeah.
For me you are.
It's just,
it's,
it's part of me is I feel like I always do the right things and the heads bowed
down as far as the,
you know,
show I'm not above people.
I'm just doing what I feel is right in life.
That's,
go get yourself some wings.
I gave myself some nice yes,
yes.
Trademark and my shit or cons.
Do you know that shit is fucking nastiest animals self like puppy ears?
No welcome.
Everybody wants to be an eagle.
Nobody wants to be a puppy.
Puppies are like way sweeter than Eagle,
Eagle Eda,
puppy mother fucker.
Right out of your hands.
Flat.
We'll see.
Took him off to a tree top and it probably is going to work.
His footwork,
you know,
he's basically,
he's got to be moving on the fucker.
Let's go.
That's rude.
He's a baby.
You know,
we got to,
the parents should have been watching the fucking kid.
Right.
It's true little bangs always training middle.
Yeah.
For Real.
If he sees the logo,
like he's watching the highlight video this morning that just got finished
today.
He sees the angel local.
He goes,
that's me.
So it's awesome.
My little boy,
his name is Dwayne Bang,
led my low boy.
So his mast and
have a third baby on the way.
And uh,
his middle name is going to be boss,
so that's going to be okay.
I was going to say,
you can't name him Dwayne to go go.
It's Duane.
Bang,
Bang.
Like George who are forming,
I guess they bought his kids George.
He did.
Yeah,
he did.
I remember that.
He was a bad motherfucker.
Yeah,
for sure.
It was just too bad to have other kids like to have kids without his name.
He's like,
nope,
nope.
I like George.
You can't name them all with George.
Yeah.
Well,
yes I can.
I can.
I will bitch.
You know who I am exactly.
Like I'm not a regular dude.
Like he feels like he can get away with shit that other people can't and he's
right.
You know,
I mean into people that try to stop that he's going to cause kids George,
and you're going to have to fucking deal with it.
That's life.
That means you're a bad man.
No,
we positioned for the fast and I got to come,
you know,
around like they said no,
but you kept help pushing for me.
And then the fans and the finally Dana white stepped in is like,
okay,
no,
it's official with the UFC.
So,
but it's only a faster by 10 hundredths or the salmon,
amateur MMA historian.
So for me it was like,
that's,
you know,
I have all these details sort of stored in my head.
I don't really carry it around on a computer.
Like I literally have all these details because I love MMA.
So for me it was always a travesty.
It was like,
we're going to bring up the record that you got to bring back a Bang Ludwig.
So someone will bring up the record.
I'll go,
well,
but it's not the real record cause Twain Ben Lowe,
which should have the fucking record.
That sounds cool.
That's just the fact that I appreciate that.
But as an a story in,
as an MMA historian,
every fight has an asterick and Jon Jones has one lot,
okay,
you can call it that.
But he beat the fuck out of Matt Hamill and he was a smashing him.
And the only reason why that 12 to six elbows illegals,
because when the athletic commission met with big John McCarthy,
they were concerned about those dudes on ESPN at six o'clock in the morning,
they're smashing bricks from your elbows feel like you can't do that brick
smashing move.
That shit's too powerful.
And so everybody's like,
all right.
But me,
while like maybe it's arguable that this elbow is more powerful than the
downward elbow,
like the downward elbow doesn't seem to have as much weight behind it as like
the,
uh,
a straight elbow.
How's it any more dangerous,
you know what I mean?
Exactly.
Doesn't make any sense,
but we're stuck with it.
We're like totally completely stuck with it.
That's legal and Thai boxing come down totally.
Should be legal.
It's an elbow.
I mean if you can hit a guy with a knee,
the face,
you're telling me you can't,
you're not fucking hard and needs the face.
You can hit them with that,
but you can't hit him with an elbow like that.
That is ridiculous and need might be three times harder than an elbow.
You know like what you see what Allister did to Travis Brown's body like God
damn nobody throws needs to the fucking body.
Like the Rheem.
He can crack some for sure.
Watching it in real life.
It's like he's doing something totally different.
Like everybody's doing one thing,
but when he's doing,
it's like he's going through your fucking body.
But that Travis Brown,
you can't teach that kind of heart.
You can't teach that shit.
That dude has zero give up in him.
It is nothing.
If he had 1% give up in him and if I show the percent the fights over,
he literally weathered the craziest
nuclear fucking winter storm,
you know,
solar fucking flares.
He weathered the craziest shit ever.
But because he didn't take it to the head,
it was all just about him having the guts and the heart to power through it.
If Alster hit him with those shots in the head,
his body would just shut off.
But because he took him to the body,
like his heart got him through one of the craziest beatings I have ever
witnessed,
anybody survived and then overcome in the same fucking Brown.
I mean that's one of the greatest come from behind rounds of all time.
I actually missed that fight.
It's gonna come back.
We were walking back through,
right?
It was in and we were walking back to the riots fight cause you were,
I was on the car.
You ride favor.
So we were walking back through the tunnel after his fight.
As they are fighting,
we're doing this doctor check and such.
So I was backstage,
but as we're walking through one of the rooms they here.
Oh.
And I'm like fuck it's ever went through it.
People ahead to the window.
And then I see Allister just dropping.
What's the craziest fight ever?
I got to watch that.
One of the craziest fights ever.
I wonder if we could show it.
I need to get permission from Dana white if we could just show these things.
Cause sometimes they pull youtube video for folks who don't know,
like if shit gets pulled off a youtube,
a lot of times there's a Bot that just searches for certain names.
Like if you write UFC in a title,
I'll just Yank our shit.
They'll just take it offline.
So you know,
why are you,
and there's a lot of videos that have me online that had been the,
they,
they put advertisements on,
there's a company does that.
They'll do it,
they'll do it for you.
Like if it's your content,
they,
they put your content online,
you put an advertising and you'd get like,
I'm just like a penny oh adsense account or something.
It's,
it's,
it's a fascinating thing.
But for the UFC they don't play.
So if it says UFC anywhere in the video they just yank it,
just pull it off.
Is there a law that if their TVs in the background and you're filming like with
your cell phone it,
that that's legal because that seems like when you ever like you searched Miley
Cyrus from like a MTV last night and it's only the ones that are like people
like filming their TV.
And that's why I always wondered if people always had like a TV behind him to
show him like video clips and stuff like that.
Cause that's kind of like
that's a,
well I know,
I do know that one thing that if you have a video,
like say if you have a video,
like a scene from a movie that that scene from a movie has a digital signature
that they can find that digital signature on like youtube.
So like a song as well.
Like a song has a digital signature and so they can do a search on that digital
signature.
So if this stays,
there's a Paul Mccartney band on the run,
the plan band on the run in a video,
they can find that that has band on the run in it somehow or another,
they can do that.
If you take it and you fill it with your phone and obviously I'm an idiot to not
listen to me here.
I'm speculating nothing about computers,
but from my idiot perspective,
I would imagine that it would have a different digital signature.
It'd be a different length.
The sound quality would be,
we would be different if you were doing it from my phone,
you'd have the ambient noise of the room that you're doing in.
You might have your breathe,
you might Fart,
and maybe a lot of shit that's on the video.
It's not in there.
So I might not recognize it,
but that's just,
I don't even know why.
Speculate like fucking wasted all your time.
People out there going,
oh yeah,
Joe Rogan says it's just
keep on questioning everything.
You can't stop on that show the question again.
The one I,
I'm done questioning things with the one with,
with the,
with chem trails that like,
I don't know either way,
I'm not fucking up there,
but there is a difference between the ones that that do dissipate.
Correct.
You know right away and the ones that stick around.
Well
absolutely not a scientist nor in anything that I will say on any,
whether it's about fucking air travel or space exploration.
Anything that I'll say on anything,
the caveat that must be stated is I don't know what the fuck I'm talking.
Yeah.
I have no education.
These subjects that I'm merely reiterating things that I've heard people say
online.
If you were to say that everyone would think so though.
You know what I mean?
You still confident about the problem problem?
Well it's just,
especially if I'm wrong and I'm super confident that that's how cold it gets
started.
The um,
yeah,
people are confident people want to listen to him,
but I'm super honest about what I know and I don't know.
I'm fucking as honest as,
as humanly possible,
even if it makes it look like an asshole.
But in in that situation,
I do know for a fact that when,
when Khan trails or more likely there's a map on the NASA website,
you can go to the NASA website and they'll show you where countries will linger
in the sky and where they won't.
In fact,
in 1942 the government was doing a research project on what they called
persistent condensation trails.
And what they discovered is during various atmosphere conditions,
whether there's a lot of moisture in the atmosphere or less moisture,
depending on what the conditions are,
it will change the length of the controls that appear behind jets.
And when you burn jet fuel,
it creates moisture.
And when you create moisture out of that burning jet fuel and it changes the
temperature of the air as it passes through like that,
you literally create a cloud.
And so when people are looking at that and thinking,
oh,
the government's spraying us with thick clouds,
it's very easy to think that it's very easy.
And this does not mean that they haven't done tests and really unethical things
with spraying aerosols from planes.
We know they have.
We know that pesticides are sprayed from planes.
Okay,
so we were,
we're familiar.
We have that archetype in our head of spraying poison.
We've seen the footage from Vietnam when they sprayed agent orange to defoliate
vast parts and jungles.
We've seen all that shit.
So we're wary of things that are sprayed from planes and you should be,
but you should also know that there is a huge difference between that and what
you're seeing in the sky on a regular basis.
And when you start saying that,
what you're seeing this guy on a regular basis is the government's spraying
chemicals.
You really throw a monkey wrench into the whole idea of them actually spraying
chemicals because first of all,
if they,
the,
the argument is they're spraying a aluminum and Barium.
Again,
I'm not a scientist,
I'm half retarded.
Again,
it took a lot of shots to the head as a youngster.
But the reality is if they did spray aluminum and Barium,
the sky wouldn't linger like a cloud.
It's a lingering like a cloud because it's a cloud.
And I know a lot of people have invested a long amount of their life wanting to
think that what they're seeing is chemicals.
And so it fucks with you because it's hard to admit you're wrong.
It's hard to change gears and we all know that.
Correct,
but in this situation,
we have to look at it.
There might be times when someone's spraying something from the sky,
but the majority of what you're seeing is just a byproduct of a jet engine going
through condensation.
And then there's the reality.
People say,
well,
are they geoengineering?
No,
but yes.
So here's the reality.
The reality is even though it's just an accidental byproduct of jet travel,
it does change the environment and it is geoengineering,
but it's not on purpose,
not on purpose.
It's just a part of flying.
If we're going to have,
there's 93,000 fucking flights a day worldwide a day,
so they're burning jet fuel in the sky above your head.
They're taking toxic fuel in fucking hundred gallon wings full of this shit.
Your wings are filled up with fucking fuel and they're burning that shit up in
the sky.
And creating clouds.
Fuck yeah,
it changes the environment,
but it's just like pollution changes the environment.
In La when you're driving on the highway,
it's not the government's sprang pollution.
Okay.
It's fucking pollution.
It's just a byproduct of human civilization and a byproduct of air travel is a,
they're burning jet fuel in the sky and be,
it creates persistent condensation trails under certain atmospheric conditions.
This is the best that I could discern after research and talking to real
experts,
but this does it and this is where he'll go,
you're a fucking Douche or permission urgent Joe Rogan's working for the
government.
You got to stop and look at this shit rationally if you're wrong about the
majority of what you see in the sky,
you discredit the possibility,
the very real possibility that things have been done.
Like there's a study about Saint Louis,
I think it was Saint Louis.
Hold on,
let,
let me,
let me pull this up.
St Louis.
There was a something that was in the news really recently that they discovered
radiation.
I think Kim trouser,
just an excuse for pansies.
I'm just like to look at clouds and there want something like a reason.
I'm just curious on what,
why,
why some stick around and white and why some don't.
Okay,
so they're here.
Well,
this is because of atmospheric conditions.
It's a difference between,
sometimes it rains and sometimes it doesn't.
Sometimes there's clouds,
sometimes there's nothing in this guy.
The conditions apparently when it's right before a crowd,
like it's Kinda hazy.
Those are the conditions that are best for creating these persistent
condensation trails and people have to understand these are fucking southwest
airlines flights you're looking at.
Sometimes people will either,
these are,
you know,
unmarked government planes,
man.
Do you really know that?
What kind of fucking Eric,
what kind of telescope do you have?
How much research have you actually done?
Or are you like me?
Do you just reiterate sure that you learn online doing this show and doing the
show on chem trails.
More people got fucking mad at me because of chem trails.
Then anything,
and I take part of the blame for that.
One of the reasons why is because I think they did a shitty job of editing it
and this is no disrespect,
but the way that people edit that show,
they have eight hours of footage.
They have to slam down to 44 minutes.
It's sit to them.
It wasn't important to totally completely explain what what causes a chemistry.
I didn't have 100% say or a contrail rather.
I didn't have 100% say as to how the show got edited.
I had say after the fact,
I would voice my opinion.
He would get overruled or they would listen to me.
It was,
it would,
it varied and in this I lost and in this I think we created a bad product.
I don't think it represented fully the the correct full explanation of what
controls are.
I think because it's such a complex issue,
I think we owed a very complex and scientific explanation,
but the problem is people think that Shit's boring.
Like what I just said right now,
the majority of people listening that would watch American idol would go pull.
What the fuck they just stopped.
Podcast is not for everybody.
You know,
and this conversation is not for everybody,
but if you want to make a TV show,
it kind of has to be for everybody for the network to acceptance until it
becomes really successful or find its niche.
And then people,
you know like South Park,
they can do whatever the fuck they want.
You know,
cause it's a proven product.
If you had another show,
we tried to make a cartoon where a gay Guy Stuffing Paris Hilton up his ass and
winning a sloughed off,
they would go,
that's the fuck are you talking about?
No you can't do that.
But South Park is so successful and it is so proven in the market that they do
that well when you shows,
not proven,
you really can't.
It's hard to like have your say as to how things get done.
It's a complex dance and I don't think we pulled it off,
but it's,
it's part of the thing of creating something,
like when you try to create a show,
I feel personally responsible for it though because a lot of people got angry
and I think a lot of that anger could have been avoided.
When I first started looking at chem trails,
uh,
online,
I too believe that it was a possibility.
Like is it possible to just pulling this off right in front of our face?
They just spraying this guy.
But then the more you look into it,
you go,
no,
there's photos from 1980 that show these controls like long ones that lingered
in the sky.
People say,
when we were younger,
they didn't linger.
Actually they did.
You just don't remember.
Pay Attention.
How much the fuck do you pay attention to?
Clouds are created by Jen when you're eight,
you know,
can you really tell me exactly what the fuck do you saw?
I barely remember shit I did last week.
I mean,
I'm being honest.
I barely remember important shit.
I get like shows that I did that were great.
I got a standing ovation at Bailey.
Remember them?
And you tell me you remember this fucking,
these,
these con trails from when you were eight years old.
Do you remember the football field that we did to fucking remember that Shit,
dude,
I learned,
I learned some stuff from Duane bank.com today,
man,
Dwayne Wade went to forget it either,
man.
But these,
these people that I'm talking to,
there's a problem with doing this show and this is why I don't know if I'm going
to continue doing it.
I mean,
first of all,
Scifi hasn't asked me to do it again,
but even if they do,
I have to really think about how it's,
I don't think I'm doing what I want to do.
I don't think it's coming out the way I want it to come out.
It's,
um,
there's part of it that is like,
there was an episode we did on transhumanism.
It's all like complicated the science of extending human life.
And I love that because I got to talk to all these super intelligent people and
pick their brain and ask really important to me questions.
I'd love that,
but talking to people that are telling me they're seeing bulletproof wolves and
goes,
shit that pops out of the reserve,
a worm hole and out came a bulletproof wolf.
Oh,
that sure happened.
I'm sure you didn't have a camera and you,
why would you while you're out there hunting for bulletproof walls.
I just,
I got tired of it.
I got tired of talking to people that are just crazy people or silly people or
people that need a fucking hug.
There's a lot of that out.
That's true.
100% and there's also a lot of people that really believe what they are saying
and it's not because they're assholes,
it's because they lack critical thinking skills,
whether no one's taught it to them,
whether they've ignored them,
whether it's the way they were raised,
whether it's the environment they grew up in,
whether it was the idea that they were exposed to as a young person.
I don't know what has caused the situation that we're talking about,
but there's a lot of people out there that are thinking in a very piss poor way
and I had been one of them in the past.
Man,
I bet I've believed in a lot of stupid shit in the past.
You know that I,
I was convinced probably was real.
There's a thing I was talking about this thing called rods.
These,
this,
this fucking,
they look like jellyfish that fly through the air faster than you could see.
There's a whole video on them.
Roswell,
bronze.
Then I watched a show called monster quest would,
they showed what they really aren't.
System of video auto fact.
Like when you have a camera and it's going on slow motion,
it's something flies past in front of it,
stretches the image out and make it,
it's a blur.
It's fucking blur.
So I was convinced that these things were flying through the air all around us
cause I'd seen this video and I was like looking for him.
The guy who made this video does not want to admit that they don't,
they don't exist.
Not only that,
he actually showed up at the UFC expo when I was doing a Q and a and he asks,
he got in line and and said he needed to talk to me about Roswell rods and he's
coming on my podcast because they are real.
And a though those people on monster quest fucked him.
And they,
they had,
I don't know how they could have fucked him because they,
they basically showed the same scene.
There was a,
a campfire or a light and a bunch of bugs were flying in front of light and they
set two cameras in front of it.
One of them was an HD super fast camera that they use for like super slow Mo.
And the other one was like a regular video camera with a regular video camera
show.
These rods there are flying across because it's an artifact.
And if you look at how it's flying across the video,
it's not flying that fast.
Like I can see it.
So how can I not see it with my eyes,
but I can see it on camera.
And then the other one just showed this just bugs.
Did you see the underwater ones and the choice?
Don't be real.
There is without a doubt.
Um,
information to government has been hiding.
Dude,
what you're doing right now is called you.
You're making a plea to ridicule rods are just tiny chem trails.
Nice.
Yeah,
they,
they might as well be,
you know,
I thought they were real man.
I really did.
You know,
I,
I saw a video once it showed that there were fucking buildings on the moon,
like display this lucky guy had he like had these images.
Oh,
even worse than that.
How about the face of Mars?
How about that motherfucker.
You ever see the face on Mars?
But there's images that people will swear to you.
The government is basically doctor does.
Second more high resolution images.
There was some photos they took a long time ago of Mars,
and as they flew over Mars,
it shows what looks like a five sided pyramid,
I think,
and a face,
a face on Mars.
Even my own friend who I loved dearly,
Graham Hancock wrote a dumb ass book about all this.
I love this friend dearly dumb.
It's dumb ass,
but he admits it was a mistake.
He admits it,
but shit,
that shit's important,
man.
Clearly it's a faith if you look at the shape,
but it does not appear in nature.
This is are two [inaudible] pitch.
You don't know what the fuck you're looking at,
okay?
You're looking at a spot that you decide that that's like looking at the clouds
and thinking that you see in dragons.
You know,
you also could be seen a fucked up cloud because cloud's aren't perfect
symmetrical squares.
You shithead.
All right,
and you're looking at some things that you barely tell.
What the fuck you're looking at.
Clearly used to faith on Martha,
and there's a dude who has these videos where he measures like these arbitrary
distances.
Like if you measure from the nose to the Left Front Center of that pyramid,
it is the exact same distance as the spanx to the pyramid of Giza.
And you're like,
how the fuck did you come to that?
Yes.
If you look at it from the White House and a 44 inch television in the corner
where Clinton used to get his blow jobs from that room,
clearly the pyramid has a face on it that looks like numbers on Mars.
I rest my case and people fucking buy the DVD and call each other on the phone
and do this some shit.
You got to see there's a man who's dropping some truth,
some mad truth about the pyramid and the next thing you know you're getting
fucking email blasts.
Have you seen this about the pyramid?
Like you motherfuckers
not a fucking face on the Mars.
They might be,
but that's not it.
I mean there might be some other shit.
It doesn't mean there's not some Osha.
It matter of fact,
the pyramid shapes on Mars are way more interesting than the um,
the face because the face when they show the high resolution image of the face,
these are,
I've been doctored,
clearly doctored.
These are not high resolution photograph.
In fact they are less than half of the gigabytes.
And it would be if it was a true 85 gallon pickle fucking picture.
But there are some like symmetrical objects that exist that do look like five,
sorry pyramids like you pull up that cause that was kind of images.
I want to see that.
Yeah.
But it's also possible that those things exist naturally.
There's a lot of weird shapes that exist naturally.
Like there's a,
there's this,
um,
I forgot what it's called.
A giant something giant's causeway,
I think in Ireland.
Let me think if that's it.
Let me see if that's it.
But it's this crazy rock formation that's totally natural.
Ireland I our wind,
I think that's what it is.
I need to get the images here.
Yeah,
that's it.
Go there.
Go go to giants causeway in Ireland and tell me this shit doesn't look like some
mother fuckers were building a building,
but it's not.
It's not at all to some weird,
crazy natural formation.
If you saw this on an image of Mars,
if someone sent you this,
clearly these are cobblestones on a I a Martian street.
They have cars like ours.
They're probably shaped like us.
Go to that.
If you find it,
look at these images.
Look at the shit.
Look at that.
Where is this now?
This is in Ireland.
Oh,
tell me if you saw that on Mars,
you wouldn't start shitting your pants.
Clearly,
sophisticated civilization,
that's just natural shit for apps.
Aliens came down and real in them took their women.
Look at that.
I mean that Shit looks so wow.
That looks so unnatural.
Hundred percent it looks like someone made a cool ass cobblestone streets,
but it's just a natural formation when these,
I don't know what the fuck causes a stones to be shaped in these weird patterns,
but look at that.
If you look at that,
you would swear that has to be made by somebody.
But it's not,
it's totally natural,
you know,
and there's varying stages of it.
They can actually see like how it's developed.
I don't know.
I'm not obviously not a,
what are they called?
What's the geologist?
Someone who understands rocks.
Those dudes,
they look at it and like there's a,
another disagreement that Graham Hancock has with some of the people.
Um,
Graham Hancock has his famous dude who wrote this book called fingerprints of
the Gods,
brilliant,
brilliant guy,
and he's exposed a lot of really fascinating shit about ancient civilizations.
And he's headed right now to go Beckley tap.
He's going to be back on the podcast in November.
He's going to go back.
Lee Typically live to check this out because go Beckley teply is essentially a,
um,
a structure that affirms all of his beliefs.
He believed that there was an ancient civilization that lived far earlier than
we're giving monitored civilization of credit for that they were capable of very
sophisticated things,
but something happened and they were most likely wiped out by like meteors or
something like that.
Well,
two things have happened since he wrote that book.
One,
the discovery,
we'll go back.
Lee tappy,
four towns,
14,000 years old,
it's as old as 14,000 years old.
Fucking massive stone pillars with animals carved in them back when they thought
that people were just like riding on horseback,
barely,
you know,
hunting,
gathering.
Like that's all they did.
Meanwhile,
they're building these insane,
huge complicated structures.
And the discovery of the impact of the Clovis comment,
they know for a fact that most likely all of the life in North America,
like all the people that live in North America were wiped out about 12,000 plus
years ago.
Oh,
I didn't know that.
A huge comet hit.
It's called the Clovis comment.
And it was like a recent discovery about a recent article that was published
about it.
So they know that there's been some shit that went down.
So because of that,
Graham has this like eager searching I and occasionally even he gets fooled,
like he'll look at something and he'll think that this thing can't be,
can't be a natural formation.
But then you look at something like the giants because when you go,
it might be like,
there's this thing in Japan off of a,
the coast edge yama,
Gucci.
I think it's an all,
I forget,
I forget the name of the place.
Go underwater.
Yeah,
really interesting shit.
But it could,
it could be natural.
If you look at this giant's causeway thing,
it could be natural too.
It could be weird.
But go to go to,
I'm Graham hancock.com and pull the images,
the underwater images of these structures.
So if you see these structures,
you can kind of see why someone could say,
man,
this is manmade.
This is definitely manmade.
But it doesn't necessarily have to be,
but that's like what's really important.
Whenever he was searching for information,
you gotta be open to all fucking possibilities.
You can't be married to something being real.
And where I think a lot like this,
they think this is,
he thinks this is like a ring of sir.
It might be.
It might,
but it's not as,
it's not a symmetrical as giant's causeway,
which we know fucking for sure is artificially is a naturally created rather.
So it's like when you come across things like this or things like chem trails,
like you gotta be really sure what the fuck you're saying.
And a lot of times people aren't,
they're just not.
One of the guys we interviewed for the show,
so really nice guys name is Michael Murphy and he wrote these documentaries.
It made his document is called what are the what in the world they sprang and
why in the world they sprang and they realize how crazy it was stressing your
show.
He's going to say crazy nutty dude.
But yeah,
we're on the same wavelengths I do.
He's just a little high strung.
You're a little high strung.
So many listen to this podcast.
All pet fucking kettle.
That should be a warning not to drink caffeine,
coffee or coffee.
Is this bulletproof?
Yeah man.
These people flying off their treadmills.
[inaudible]
fuck yeah,
I know you.
I don't have to,
I don't even have to drink caffeine for practice or anything cause he gets me
going.
Some of
this stuff is awesome too.
This bulletproof stuff.
A lot of people saying like they give you heart attacks,
whatever bitch,
what are you a pussy?
I drink it to heart attack.
I don't know if it gives you,
I think that cholesterol most certainly is probably bad for you if you live the
average American life.
But you know what's really bad for you?
The average American lives.
Zach,
that's what's bad for you.
I on the other hand,
I can drink this shit all day long cause I work out like a terrorist.
Right.
Wait a sec.
Did you hear that?
Uh,
Uber is a purchasing 2,500 of those driverless cars.
And can you imagine now like just being on your phone and like pick me up and
it's like,
you know,
car with no person in it picks you up that's coming,
that's coming for sure.
Those called taxis.
Well,
you know,
my car,
I got an infinity and it recognizes the distance between the car in front of me
and slows down.
And then when the car goes further,
it speeds up.
Like say if you set your,
your set your speed limit,
you set it to 65 and the cruise control and it knows where you're going.
Wow.
It slows you down.
Like you could just let your foot off the pedal and just chill.
And it like,
you know,
you have to have your foot ready to break.
Some deer runs across actually not supposed to break.
Right.
But here goes in front of you just [inaudible].
Sure.
That sucks man.
It's hard to do for each.
Have a nice car.
Free dear me fucking deer's going right through your windshield.
Especially if a Miata or some shit.
You an elk.
I
might want it to break.
Yeah,
I mean Yada stopped pretty quick.
Yeah.
You don't want to hit a fucking eloquently when our surroundings for sure.
There was a,
um,
a show that I watched called pig man.
You ever watch that show?
This motherfucker.
First of all,
the reason why I brought this up,
did they have these trucks with these giant grills in the front of them because
there's so many wild deer and wild pigs in Texas that they just run into those
bitches on the highway all the time and they will fuck your car up.
So dudes have special bumpers on their car just designed to smash into it.
It's like some Mad Max shit.
Like see,
you have this gigantic pickup truck would just fucking battle battering ram that
has it.
Literally like cuts like a v straight towards the F.
I mean these are crazy fucking bumper.
The show they were,
it's called a pork lips 2013 pull the video up cause I put it on Twitter.
This is the nuttiest fucking Shit I've ever seen in my life.
Nadeer then this is a Buddhist,
a area of Japan where they feel that deer sacred and is a video that I tweeted
about all these deer everywhere.
This is not the important trips in it.
Really cute.
They're delicious.
I'll shoot those fuckers.
I would shoot him right there.
Everybody went to sleep.
Pull out a bow and Arrow shooting.
I'm opening the UFC,
goes back to Japan and when these guys found in the car and I'm Mr Pan going on
with another one of those trips where I could actually eat food and relax and
not stress about my own fight.
Yeah,
that'd be good.
Pull that.
Pull that on the video up.
Cause it's,
it's a crazy thing to look at.
Okay.
The heat,
they're shooting pigs from helicopter.
Okay.
Oh,
I see a new one though.
This is a two parter.
They did it last year and uh,
it was uh,
let there be pork I think.
But this is a pork lips 2013 and there's,
it's a two parter.
And when one of them,
he shooting bows and arrows,
he shooting bows and arrows out of a fucking helicopter and pigs,
yes.
Way.
And killing him.
He said it's the only time it's ever been done.
Yeah,
for sure.
It killed three pigs with a bone.
Now listen to this because this is fucking crazy.
It's hard enough to shoot a bow and Arrow made ground.
This is the craziest thing the sportsman channel has ever done coast to coast
across the hardware.
They're sending it up like saint these pigs are dangerous,
which is true.
But look at this
pig man and Ted Nugent.
This might be one of the greatest,
I mean look,
I'm not,
I'm not a fucking heartless person,
but there is a reality that they have a real problem with these wild pigs and
there is a problem with feeding hungry people as well.
They absolutely donate all of that meat to hunters for the handling of that.
That yeah,
I shouldn't have fucking bow and Arrow with a pig from a helicopter hunters for
the hungry.
They uh,
they donate all this meat.
So this meat goes to needy families.
It's really good wild game.
It's very healthy for you.
And these people are very fortunate to be able to get free meals like this.
Yup.
Yeah.
That's sad.
They're not hunting.
Okay.
There are rattling.
Just shot it with a bow and arrow.
They're eradicating what they consider to be problem animals and say,
well,
humans are fucking problem animals like this or this one animal rights activist.
When fuck had bananas when I posted this video.
It was really interesting.
I watch this,
read his timeline.
He was calling for a Ted Nugent to a fight him at a bar fight to you was calling
him to either kill himself or die like over and over again,
calling from to die or you years to meet me.
You want to kill a person.
But meanwhile you like this,
this animal killing bothers you.
So you want to commit violence and the person you,
you're protecting the animals by also acting violently.
Yeah.
Did I got so much crap on Twitter for when I went bear hunting and got a giant
bear
grizzly?
Uh,
no brown black bear.
So de jete it.
Uh,
so we donated all the meat to the local Indians.
I hunted on a,
the crow Indian reservation in Montana and the bear that I killed,
I don't it to the local Indians there.
Cause I mean,
you mean you should see this Indian reservation,
how they're living,
you know,
it's,
it's pretty bad.
And a giant bear and posted it on Twitter and people were eating me up over it.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
They don't realize that by me doing that,
I'm actually helping out the population of other animals in the bear at that
time.
The bears,
they'll kill their own cubs so that they can meet again.
You know what I mean?
Yes.
Yeah.
Well,
if they're in a bad situation where there's low resources,
you know,
people don't like the idea that the resources have to be maintained and that if
you really study it and it's so hard to do,
but try to talk to someone who really understands game conservation and try to
study it from an objective perspective because there is a certain amount of
predators that can exist in an environment and there's a certain amount of prey
that can exist in an environment and they know what that number is and they know
how to manage that and they're very diligent about it.
They changed the limits all the time.
Like they do it with the salmon population in Alaska.
They monitor it very closely with salmon weirs.
They make sure that the populations are healthy.
Then you're good numbers running through.
So you know,
people can or can't fish.
They open seasons,
close seasons on a whim.
If they go,
look,
you was on a fish coming through this,
we're boom,
they shut the season down.
And that's,
that's called responsible management.
If you don't have responsible management for wildlife,
especially when it comes to deer,
you get overpopulation and you get fucking disease.
They get a lot of wasting disease.
You get Lyme disease,
which spreads throughout the east coast.
There's people that are fucked up from Lyme disease and Lyme disease comes from
deer ticks.
And people have to understand like there's more,
and I read this recently,
no,
Ted Nugent told me this recently,
not me.
I mean he doesn't like me,
but if you can talk,
probably thinks I'm a liberal.
But if even if you talked,
you know,
he a on his show,
he was talking about how there is more wildlife as far as deer and as far as
coyotes and as far as like whatever wild game and this country now than when
Christopher Columbus came here.
Oh whoa.
How fucking crazy.
First of all,
how the fuck do you know
to count back then?
But second of all,
if he's right and the idea is that with less,
um,
less forest than they used to be back then,
like before it was like fucking forest everywhere.
The deforestation is created,
larger areas like agriculture has created much more opportunity for dirty.
So there's more deer now than ever before.
They're more successful because there's less like mountain lions around shit
because there's people around,
they hear the cars and shit,
they're not loose like running to the,
yeah.
So they like,
they're getting to breed more and you got to manage that population because if
you don't,
you have deaths on the road.
Not just the deer,
but people.
I mean,
if you've ever googled dear through windshield,
you know,
you want to see some horrific fucking scenes of destruction.
People die every year because deer go through their windshield and a lot of
folks don't know that,
but a deer is a fucking hundred and 80 pound hunk of bones and steak and you hit
it with your car and you're a fucked man.
You know,
stop trying to be cute.
I'll show you some cows to bitch eat cheeseburgers like a motherfucker had.
People don't realize either the money you pay for those tags to go kill that
animal to your donating that money to the wildlife federation.
You know,
like I just spent over 400 bucks on a deer tag in the route for the Ruby
mountains.
In fact,
punters donate more money for conservation and have more impact on conservation
because of the amount of money they spend on tax then any pro animal rights
group.
Absolutely.
Then Annie and the amount of money that you get from tags and from management,
you can't just leave them alone like people be like,
let go,
let them go low.
You have to understand that you're a fucking animal too,
right?
There's a delicate game that's going on between us and all the other and yes,
as the highest intellectual animal with thumbs on the planet earth,
not in the ocean.
You know,
it's debatable whether or not we're smarter than dolphins.
If we can't understand the language and they can understand us,
I think it's debatable,
but as the smartest the most,
and the one who's looking like,
what's the best case scenario for mankind?
Well,
no more war.
Love your brother.
Everybody gets along.
We have the perfect civilization in a hundred years and we all get our shit
together.
We all agree that you can't show cruelty to animals and make that happen.
You can't be stopping people's cats shooting people's dogs.
And so we associate our dogs and our pets who we love very much our cats and
what have you.
We associate that with wild animals,
but that's some baby shit,
okay?
Because wild animals will fucking eat your ass hole.
If you go out there and you go wandering around and you fall down,
you sprain your ankle and a fucking bunch of wolves find you.
Guess what?
Fuck face.
That's a wrap.
And the only thing that keeps those wolves from doing that is they know we have
the bank sticks and the cars and all this shit that they're scared of misplaced.
Stay the fuck away.
That's it.
It's not.
The wolves aren't beautiful man.
I fucking love wolves.
I think they're majestic.
I watched documentaries on boils.
I bet.
I've watched a hundred documentaries on walls.
I watched the documentary about the dude who live with the wolves and it's
gigantic wildlife containment,
and he would actually stuff a liver into the carcass so that he could prove that
he was the Alpha deliver first and it was loud.
All the other boys,
I guess.
Crazy fascinating.
I think they're amazing and I'm so glad they're alive,
but if one of them is following me,
I'll shoot it right in the deck.
Oh yeah.
In a
heartbeat.
If I had gone in a wolf was following me,
I'd be like,
are you fucking crazy?
I have kids.
You fucking punk.
Most of the information I know that you're talking about is actually coming from
the podcast.
Might fuck it.
Up.
Dot,
dot,
dot.
It doesn't mean I don't love wolves.
I do love walls,
but if I thought a wolf is going to eat me,
I would fucking kill it.
Like you have to do that and people have to understand that.
That used to be a really common occurrence.
People Killed Wolves all the time.
Between 15 something of 250 year period in Paris,
wolves killed 3000 people in France.
Wow.
Wrap your fucking dude.
That's a lot of fucking people.
They're smart.
Sneaky things that eat meat.
Okay.
What are we stupid lazy fucks that get drunk and were made out of meat.
All right.
It's pretty fucking simple,
but everybody wants to look at them.
It's like beautiful and that's when they said,
you know,
if he amazing.
Yes.
Amazing.
Also they have to be managed.
If I had a,
if I had a home I own me,
I probably wouldn't have to kind of harder to say that you have wireless.
I got to the point.
Yeah.
The kids were starving and it was wintertime and you gotta fuck.
Yeah,
you would.
I know you are.
You kidding me?
You just kind.
If you don't have to be mean to the point.
Yeah.
Then yeah,
things have changed for sure.
I wouldn't do it right now for fine.
She never do it for fun and that's why it's fucked up to watch this pig man
thing because on one hand I agree that they have to do what they're doing.
Like those,
those pigs cause devastation to wildlife.
They caused aro accidents left and right.
They want across the roads,
they're fucking,
they've fucking devastate farms and cost people who have these lands,
this land,
their family banks on it costs them a lot of fucking money.
That is reality.
And then there's also reacted.
They're alive for them,
their life or maybe maybe they shouldn't be shot in the head with machine guns
from a helicopter terrorizing it.
Also making money off it,
but like making it seem cool to kill animals and stuff.
You're right,
you're right.
But then again,
the food goes to the,
they have to be killed because they do the our problem.
There's so many,
I don't know if it's true,
but I read this so let's just repeat it.
There's almost as many pigs in taxes as there are people wrap your fucking head
around that.
There's almost as many,
let's just Google that.
Texas is a big ass place too.
There's a lot of pigs there
and we're not talking about women dare you.
How dare you shame those women.
You're fat shaming,
shaming assholes.
Very nice.
Fat Shamer I bet you slept shame to you.
Asshole.
Slut shaming.
Fat Shame.
I'm numbering in the millions.
These shockingly destructive and invasive wild hogs wreck havoc across the
southern United States.
Well there's so fucking like strong and tough wild pigs that what happens is
domestic pigs get out and it's a weird thing,
but within three weeks of being out in the wild,
fending from their self,
their body actually starts changing.
The hair grows coarser than extends the tusks grow.
It's nuts,
man.
Quick evolution.
And they are not shy about fucking,
they fuck up warm.
And then they just had,
they start dominating.
They just start taking over land and they don't have very many natural
predators.
So there's,
there's apparently they do 400 million in damages annually.
Well
God damn,
that's a lot.
That's good.
They also,
they also cause fish kills because they fuck with ponds.
So monthly stomp around in them that they get the ponds.
So muddy from running around in them that they,
uh,
they,
they choke off the fish.
They're nuts,
man.
Dad raised pigs growing up to sell for four h for auction and a dude,
they're a pain to deal with.
I mean,
they mess up everything to tear down your fences.
They,
you know,
they cause more problems than,
than they are to take care of for sure.
Okay.
There's,
this might not be right.
Um,
what I said might not be right about it,
the numbers of people because apparently,
but the number of this are,
the other article which is on NBC says that they cause one point $5 billion in
damages nationwide each year,
which is,
you know,
the other ones just Texas and there's currently more than 5 million wild hogs,
the United States.
And within a few years they're saying that the number of feral hogs is going to
triple five years in Texas,
triple fucking triple the Nydia hunting.
So they ha,
they literally almost have to do this with a,
shooting them out of helicopters.
They carry crazy amounts of diseases and unless you want to just start fucking
reintroducing wolves to Texas,
you gotta take care of these mother fuckers.
You,
there's something's got to eat them.
You can't just have these things.
You have an imbalance.
The reason why these millions of wild hogs running through these fields is
because there's nothing killing them.
They're not supposed to be there.
Like if there's a problem.
And so you have to figure out a really extreme method of solving his problem,
then there's no more extreme method.
Did Ted Nugent and the pig man in a fucking helicopter with machine guns and yes
and no.
Yes.
It's cruel.
It's horrible.
Yes.
I'm an animal lover.
I have two cats and two dogs,
but I fucking saved this shit on my DVR.
I'm going to watch it again.
I need to watch.
I can't live this shooter with a bow.
That's insanity.
Well,
he misses the first shot because there's a,
he asked to actually a factor for the wind coming in with a helicopter.
Imagine pushing the Arrow down so it's shot like low.
So yes to like sort of lead it fucking fascinating.
And you don't have sites for that.
That's a judgment,
you know what I mean?
Meanwhile he misses the first shot.
Second shot,
hot shot,
hot shot may just in scale is thing.
Oh he's been fucking super deadly accurate in the yeah.
Yeah.
And again,
horrible and sad that these poor animals have to die.
But there,
there is an imbalance.
And as the stewards of the land,
I think either there's a good argument that humans are supposed to maintain that
shit.
You know what,
get more rip better ratings though.
If they just had like a big one of the big guys shots and they just put
pigs and tried to see how far they could flip them.
Well it's hard to catch the pigs.
They do a catch the pigs and knife them on.
Some of the episodes they catch the pigs with dogs,
they have to substance separate types of dogs.
One dog finds the pigs and bathe them and then the pit bulls come in and then
the pit bulls have like leather vests on so the hog can't rip them apart.
And they just lock on him and hang on and then they come and kill him with a
knife.
Oh Wow.
That's a process.
It's fucking gang teamwork.
Yeah.
And it's crazy to watch because it is as primal as it get.
And I think the only reason why people aren't watching it is because it's on the
sportsmans channel.
I mean,
who goes to Chels six oh five on direct TV.
You gotta be looking for some weird porn.
Did that high up on,
you know,
that's like right after it was like porn in Spanish.
It's like those are those weird channels.
Like how'd you get over there?
You know?
Except like fuel fuel's in that range,
right?
Yeah.
There's a lot of great advice for hundreds of years.
That's like the fucking UFC network,
man.
I didn't even know that they had new a,
that's the network.
The Fox one.
Fox sports one.
Oh,
it's incredible.
The ratings for Spock's Fox sports one were off the charts for the first UFC
card.
That's why they put together that insane card.
I mean that car that was a good car.
Nasty jail son and versus Shogun.
Crazy.
Before that Alastair versus Travis Brown.
I mean there was Matt Brown versus,
Oh yeah,
Jesus Christ.
There's so many good fights.
My pile.
Yeah,
quicksand.
There's so many good fights on that card.
It was like one good fight after another good fight.
It was like a paper view where the cars,
yes,
for sure.
I mean,
you know,
a lot of people were upset about the son who AFI both are a little bit past her
prime.
She has lost a couple of fights in a row,
but what a fucking great fight it turned out to be.
You know,
and you know,
you've got to see the child can still finish guys.
People sleep on that Shit,
man.
That guy is a beast.
It's a whole your neck man.
He's going to,
he knows how to finish guys too,
just because he hasn't done a lot of guys.
If you watch the way he closed off,
Brian Stann dad is not a dude.
He's just doing that for the first time.
That's a dude who's really good at finishing people.
He just hasn't been doing it.
Yeah,
that's the thing.
Tough dudes,
man.
Absolutely.
Really tough guys.
He's been fighting the top of the food chain guys.
It's like,
well we went back to,
when we're talking about mighty mouse,
like people say mighty mouse is boring,
bitch you crazy.
He's exciting as hell.
He's like one of the most exciting guys ever.
It's just,
he's fighting guys who are almost a mirror image of him when he's fighting
Benevidez and when he's fighting,
uh,
Ian Mccall,
those guys are so fucking good.
You know,
you're just in the mix with this,
you know,
the techniques are like jai shot in each other off and pulled.
Got Yeah,
exactly.
I can't wait until benefited us and no mighty mouse.
Right.
Again,
that's going to be good.
This with September 4th cause for Miga in Brazil and then hopefully get the
title shot after that.
How old is he now?
88.
Do you think that um,
it used to be that,
uh,
the lighter weights,
like where they were much better when they were in the youngest?
Yeah,
the youngest age.
Like how old are you?
I'm 27.
Yeah.
Like that's like a perfect time to be developing
between like 22 and he's like 29 30 but like with a heavyweight guys are sort of
coming into their prime when they're hitting like 30 and 31 like it seems like
the larger men learn how to move their body better later in life.
Okay.
Whereas like younger guys,
they seem to like hit the threshold of where they kind of peak and fade off
earlier.
Do you feel that that's accurate?
I'm not even lighter.
Guys have to start watch this.
I feel like I've gotten stronger now that I've gotten older.
You know,
I feel like I've got a little more man to man muscle and stuff,
you know?
I feel like I've gotten stronger that way.
You just got,
Brian's got a hard on
more boner pills.
What age?
What is the most successful older,
lightest weight fighter?
Because you know,
obviously have Randy,
who's the most successful,
the oldest like high level fighter was Randy because Randy was like world title
fights at 46 he was fighting Machida at 48 you know,
finding very high level.
Shoot your eyes,
fill him pretty good.
And he's what?
34 34 35 yeah,
so he's probably the oldest of the,
the high level and I'm lighter weight guys.
Yeah,
and hasn't lost a step is it's getting better.
The whole team is just kicking ass,
man.
It's fucking,
it's fun as hell for me to be there,
man.
Do you have an alternative name if Alpha males,
the whole team,
if what?
If it becomes to bank zillions.
I got that from actual UFC mags and I didn't create that.
I like it.
That's,
I like that.
We go with that bank zillions.
Yep.
You're going to need some sort of a Brazilian element.
You got to bring in zone yet
Ben Zillions and Zillions zillion.
Do you guys,
you train with zero there now at the professor Fabio brought,
we're an American bank.
American Bank.
Some banks.
Can you get the bank going to be secondary?
It can be a team effort.
It can be bang,
Bang.
I see.
I understand.
Tweeting that I've just had a great bang.
Their tweets or [inaudible] that doesn't help the do Schellman [inaudible] does
that for sure.
Everybody wants to bang,
but if you just say,
yeah,
I'm going to go bang.
My girlfriend was like huge fuck.
Strange,
huge.
It's like there's a fine line between what everybody,
right.
Once in what everybody talks about and you gotta be real careful about that
because everybody wants to fuck.
But if you talk about fucking,
she's scared to admit it.
Ridicule,
Bang with girlfriend twice,
Bro.
Man,
put that on Twitter,
man.
You're putting it on Twitter and you just going to get
cool
as if that's not what everybody wants.
You know,
I don't mind it.
I got three kids now.
Hold one on the way though.
It's like one of those things where it's like if you were really rich and you
start bragging about it,
people like there's a lot of people are poor.
So if you're like captain fucks a lot and hustling and Dick like a Ninja,
uh,
you know,
having sex with Jessica Biel and putting pictures of her ass on Twitter,
right?
Tall.
It bothers
people.
Like there's a photo,
like,
let's be honest,
there's a photo of Jenny McCarthy with a Donny Walberg and we saw it on,
see it,
whatever the fuck it was.
CNN breaking news.
Donnie Wahlberg put his penis inside of Jenny McCarthy.
I wonder if they got vaccinated before they did it.
But you look at the picture,
we like look at,
Oh,
he gets bang her.
Oh Shit.
What are your thoughts?
Vaccines.
My kids are in the backseat.
I think some vaccines are very important.
I think there's a lot of vaccines for sure.
And there's a,
there's different protocols that people follow.
There's some doctors that have a protocol where you,
uh,
slowly vaccinate your children instead of giving them a gigantic amount of,
and I think that is,
look,
you're not supposed to give babies peanut butter man.
You know,
Peter,
if you give peanut butter to babies that you know,
you,
you'd never know if your kid's allergic to peanuts.
So you have to find out,
like babies are super sensitive and very delicate and they're very fragile.
That said,
the human immune system without a doubt has benefited from vaccines.
You know,
I just don't know if we have too many of them or if in the past,
I know for a fact and I'm a supporter of vaccines without a doubt.
I don't want to be even blurry about this.
I think vaccines have changed this world and have made society safe for us from
a lot of different ailments that said nothing is perfect.
And for sure without without doubt,
there have been people that have been harmed by vaccines.
The question is,
is it worth that risk,
um,
to,
to continue vaccinating people?
Is it worth the risk that the one out of x people have received damage?
I personally think,
yes,
I've personally think yes and I personally think you should proceed with caution
and I think you should.
I mean there should be a lot of different things that you read about from very
educated people about the subject.
And the reality is at educated people,
for the most part,
agree that vaccines are important bullet,
but through objective ones are willing to admit that people have been damaged by
vaccines before.
I have a friend and her fucking dad has Lyme disease and he got it from a
vaccine and he got it from a vaccine they don't even use anymore because some
people had a genetic predisposition to being adversely affected by this vaccine.
So we're fucking,
dad has Lyme disease man,
and he took a vaccine so that he wouldn't get Lyme disease because he was scared
of it.
His wife took the same vaccine,
nothing.
She actually got vaccinated from Lyme disease and it works.
But for him,
he got Lyme disease from it.
So that's that is inaction benefit and and a detraction and a negative effect of
vaccines.
I think that for the most part though,
look man,
there's a lot of fucking diseases we've eradicated like polio.
There's a lot of shit that we've removed but now like means those are starting
to come back.
You know,
people are,
there's certain diseases that we thought we got rid of the people starting to
get and one of the blame for that is that people aren't vaccinating their kids
for measles.
There's certain,
there's like a lot of people were afraid because the word was that it was the
measles,
mumps and rubella IA.
That was the one that was the,
the vaccine.
It was giving people,
you know,
all sorts of health and there's been lawsuits,
man.
That's what other people,
a lot of people don't realize is a lot of money has been given out in vaccine
court for damage that was caused by vaccines.
Doesn't mean the vaccines are bad.
It's again,
it's one of those really complicated nuanced issues where it's not a fucking
grand design of Eugenics by the elite to control the population and dumb us
down.
It's not,
it's doctors trying to solve pandemic diseases can we were being serious six
civilization.
It was one of the more interesting things,
uh,
about my show was,
to me getting to talk to these a disease specialists and scientists and doctors
that we're talking about various pandemic diseases,
how many people are affected by tropical diseases that we're talking about.
People in pour like Africa and tropical environments where like everyone has
parasites,
everyone has certain diseases and like sexual diseases that are super dangerous.
Like the type of syphilis that you can't cure.
And then all these morphing,
changing diseases,
they're trying to constantly stay on top of these fucking things and they're
there.
There's diseases like mirrors.
You ever heard of Merced?
There's some disease called murs that kills literally half the people that it
gets infected by or half the people that didn't get infected with it.
There's,
there's nutty shit out there and there's doctors that are sticker rambling to
try to procure these things and try to come up with vaccines and,
but in the process,
sometimes there's damage.
You know,
you said you talked about this,
I'm one of your shows that came out.
Yeah.
On the Joe Rogan questions,
everything show aired.
Yes.
Yeah.
That was like,
uh,
let's,
let's find this out payouts.
That was a,
I think it was two weeks ago.
Then last week everybody got mad at me again.
That was it.
Okay.
One,
nobody got mad at me,
but then last week was aliens.
It never was like,
dude,
you did not provide the,
I got all these,
how come you didn't show this video and this,
that puts this on my message board.
Clearly there's a wormhole like pitch that's someone's headline that's
headlights on a dark.
Meanwhile it's like you barely can see what the fuck that is,
man.
So,
oh my God,
I really imagine this stuff you've got to deal with.
Oh God.
The amount of fucking people that have been paid out in vaccine court.
There's a lot of pans.
Yeah.
It's like it happens all the time apparently.
Well not all the time,
but it's been millions of dollars to new cases are pretty here.
Vaccine Court awards,
millions to two children with autism.
Wow.
So that's the thing that people say that no vaccines don't cause autism.
And that's the argument.
Like some say it does and some say it doesn't.
It's,
it's the,
I don't know,
man.
I'm not a fucking doctor.
That's a real problem.
When I look at this kind of data is I have the saying that it's terrifying when
you're too stupid to know who's dumb.
You know?
That's,
that's how I feel about this stuff because when I read that,
that a court awarded millions of dollars to two children with autism vaccine
court awards,
millions to two children with.
Awesome.
I read that and I say,
okay,
well that means vaccines cause autism.
Is that what that means?
I didn't list that.
Had a couple of shots with autism in it,
but they don't have autism in a shot.
As far as I know.
We've got the autism.
Hannah poling developed an autistic condition after receiving nine vaccines in
one day following the u s government because seating or case in 2008 her damages
are awarded over her lifetime reported to be $20 million.
Oh my God.
Hmm.
May mean what does that mean then?
I don't,
I don't know what that means.
Does that mean that vaccine cause autism?
Cause that's what it sounds like.
How did they know that she didn't have autism before she got the shots?
That's a good question.
That's a very good question.
And if that's the case and how the fuck did they award,
how did that,
how'd that work out?
They gave her a $20 million.
Like is it just then the question is,
is it just bad court decision?
Is it just an uninformed,
is that what it is?
I don't understand.
Well,
this is,
listen,
listen to this.
Since 1989 and as of January of 2013 over two point $5 billion have been paid
out from this vaccine caused injury and death compensation fund.
So two point $5 billion had been paid out from the vaccine caused injury and
death competition.
When these are numbers that I'm,
I'm reading off of like these are legitimate websites,
this isn't,
this isn't like,
we're not just making things up.
This is,
these are not propaganda websites and the,
they're not trying to hide this 9,785 claims have been dismissed and of those
claims,
3,982 claimants were paid $52 million to cover their attorney's fees and other
legal costs.
So they were paid.
Even the people were there,
the,
the claims were dismissed.
They paid their legal fees.
Like what are they doing there?
They just saying,
listen bitch,
I know you a lot of legal money and just let it go.
I know you're trying to fight in this,
you know,
we're gonna win.
I don't know,
but it's,
it is fascinating.
I don't understand it,
but I know that like when Jenny Mccarthy talks about vaccines and causing your
kid autism,
I have heard dudes were like the most progressive,
like male feminists,
like really like kind towards women.
Say some of the most nasty fucking evil shit to Jenny McCarthy because,
because you're allowed to because she expresses a very specific opinion about
vaccines and she's obviously not a fucking doctor and they think that what she's
doing is scaring people into not having vaccines and into a,
you know,
creating death and illness.
I maybe,
yeah,
maybe,
I don't know,
but maybe you need to pay attention to what the fuck I just read that seems like
it's,
that seems real new.
Jersey girl gets four point $7 million for vaccine injuries.
Here's another one.
This is from 2002 in New Jersey.
Girl who's mental development was stopped at two months old after a routine
immunization has received a four point $7 million settlement from a national
trust one.
I mean,
what the fuck is going on,
man?
What does that mean?
I don't know if that means that,
I mean in my dumb mind,
I read that and I,
you know,
it doesn't that,
what's that expression?
Causation does not equal something else.
What does that expression,
how's it going?
No,
causation doesn't.
If you want to seem smart on the Internet,
you have to repeat this because it does not look at that.
Jenny McCarthy.
Cool.
Okay.
Does not imply correlation.
So,
so just because something was caused,
it doesn't mean it was,
it's correlated with what you're blaming it on.
Like there's a lot of other factors involved,
but millions of fucking dollars,
man,
billions even given out.
So that's my opinion about vaccines.
I think they're very,
very important.
I think the people that are working on vaccines and that are fighting against
pandemic diseases are doing an amazing job of keeping people safe and they've
eradicated some really fucking dangerous,
horrible pandemic diseases.
That said,
obviously some people it fucks up or it seems to at least,
and I think it's not an either or situation.
I think people have to be really careful about that because if you're,
if you're rallying against these people that are talking badly about vaccines,
but then these facts are real and are available,
what are you doing?
Like what are you saying?
It's not an either or.
It's it's this,
there's a lot of complication there.
A lot of chance,
Huh?
It seems like it.
Yeah.
I mean,
from my uneducated perspective,
when I read that,
and again,
causation does not equal correlation known how smart I am.
Um,
I think that,
uh,
you got to say that there's,
you know,
there's obviously it's not that cut and dry.
It's not like I'm going to the,
uh,
the supreme court because I believe that a wizard made by Dick's mom,
you know,
and then the supreme court gives me $1 billion.
That seems,
that seems like how the white balls are fucking evidence.
I have a small deck.
Shouldn't miss.
So there you go.
I mean,
there you talking about,
you know,
it's not that it's not that fucking stupid.
That's the,
that's the answer.
That's my answer on chem trails.
And it's my answer on vaccines to very complicated issues that a lot of people
get real fucker.
We don't have the tinfoil.
So yes or no,
it might be that,
but it's also that people attach themselves to the ship.
They believe they want something to be fill a part of and have something to
fight for that.
Yeah.
And if they said something,
if like you say,
you know the fucking rainbows are created by Gremlins Bro.
And then you start telling people that and you make a video and you put it on
Youtube,
man,
you're committed to that shit.
And there's a lot of people out there committed to some really iffy ideas.
Like,
why are you coming?
Are you sure?
Are you fucking sure?
Shouldn't be sure man.
Not a lot of fuckery to this world.
Like when you said that you think that,
um,
you create your own destiny.
Everything happens for a reason.
You might be right.
You know,
anybody says you're not right.
It's crazy.
If you say,
if you believe it,
you can achieve it.
Well,
you have so what the fuck do they know?
Maybe.
Maybe that is how the world works.
Maybe the world works by your imagination manifesting reality.
Maybe the world works by your intention and your focus literally changing the
world around you,
creating things and opportunities that would not have existed or been in front
of you if you didn't do that work.
If you didn't experience the those,
those revelations and evolutions of your spirit,
maybe you don't fucking know that's possible too,
because the world's not that fucking simple.
There's a God damn reason why when you hear a certain song,
it reminds you of a certain time in your life or a certain person you knew and
you have this intense emotional create a reaction to it.
And the,
the,
the beats of the music change your body.
You know,
there's certain times where you're by yourself and sweet home.
Alabama comes on the radio at just the right time.
And when it says turn it up,
don't,
I know.
And it changes your body.
It's the world is not just made out of numbers and it's not just made at a hard
surfaces and it's not just made it a things you can way.
There's also some weird spiritual aspect to this world,
you know,
and I don't,
I don't,
I think you,
you manifest a lot of it with your attitude and your behavior and your actions.
And I don't know how much of it would have been there without that.
I don't know.
I think it's both.
You know,
If a brick drops in your head,
it will fucking kill you.
That's true too.
You know,
sometimes shit happens,
man.
Look,
the fucking war,
the dinosaurs asking for that big asteroid hit.
Not,
no,
probably not.
You know,
I don't know if that,
I don't know if it's that simple.
I think it's both.
It's both.
You create your reality and shit happens.
That too.
Shit fucking happen.
You didn't ask to break your ankle in that fight.
Why did that happen?
That's some shit happens.
Right.
So I'm wondering,
you know,
things are predetermined for some point that that just kind of led me to make
the decision.
Okay,
55 is too low of a weight class.
I'm just destroying my body in the knee.
Injuries is just coming too easy.
Maybe if I was at 70 million,
my ankle would have rolled a bit differently.
You know,
we have more stability.
Just cutting to wait,
you know,
depleting the body too much.
So that was my last fight at 55 which made me go up to 70 so yeah.
You know,
who knows.
It could have been or it could have been that you realized after that that you
needed to make a change and being the winner,
that you are felt the right path and went down it and it succeeded because
that's what you do.
You dust yourself off,
you figure out what went wrong and you move forward and that's what you did do.
So it could have been things happen for a reason or it could have been the
reason things happen is because you're a winner.
Yeah.
It makes the role that one you can control.
See that what I like about that one is that one,
you can control.
And that one seems to make more sense because everybody that I know that has
ever succeeded in things,
they're winners.
They're winners.
They have,
they have that ability to fucking figure out how to get up when they don't want
to get up.
They have that ability to do the things that they have to do,
putting the work that they have to put in,
get shit done.
And the people that don't,
we all know super talented fighters that never made it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's true.
There's a lot of guys out there shot yet.
There's a lot of guys out there that had that special something and it never
could put it together.
There's a few guys that shown so greatly in like preliminary fights and you're
like,
this motherfucker's a world champion.
Now you're looking at it and be like this guy and you hear from the people,
Oh,
in the gym,
he dominates everybody.
There's so many fine or something like that.
How many,
how many times you heard that about Joe rigs.
Oh,
that's right.
You had to hear about the drover.
Exactly.
He's a bad
ass.
A Joe raise used to dominate rich Franklin and the gym that they would be
sparked and Joe Briggs just be lightened rich Franklin up,
but in competition can put it really well.
He had some great fights and he had some great results and he had a long career
and he's a,
he's still a bad motherfucker and a great professional fighter,
but if you listen to people talk,
they said they make Joe rigs out to be Anderson Silva.
They make Joe rigs out to be some magic man.
You know,
some,
some dude that on perfect moments on the right moments.
Like I remember talking to Billy Rush before he died and uh,
Billy Rush was training those guys and he,
and he said to me,
he goes,
he's one of the greatest talents I've ever seen.
He said,
this fucking kid can do it all.
And he does it all like perfect in,
in spurts in the gym and you know,
and when he's his head's right,
you know,
and then shit happens.
And that crazy world of,
of,
of chaos and sometimes it doesn't come together for you.
You know,
if it's the reason that everything happens for a reason,
then there's some people that got some dealt some shitty cards,
you know what I mean?
If everything happened for reasons,
like there's a lot of things you can't explain,
you know,
and in the world of prize fighting,
I think that shit manifests itself in such a strange and dramatic way because
the difference between winning and losing is so much more extreme than golf or
tennis or anything else.
So we have our options.
It's not just so many more options.
It's so much more devastating results.
You know,
you can lose a tennis match and you'd go home and you're fine.
like if you lose an MMA fight,
your health can change.
The structure of your face looks different.
You have to get plates in your face,
you have to get your,
you know,
your face stitched up.
Can't breathe out of my nose.
I'm sure almost everybody has that right?
Yeah.
I had mine operated on a few years.
You sweetest thing I've ever done all my life.
I was a mouth breather.
I broke my nose when I was like five.
I fell down a flight of stairs and it was always like,
I'll just,
I nasal,
I had a nasal sound to my voice and I mouth breathed every practice.
Everything I ever did was mouth breathing.
Yeah.
These guys and make sure their bite down on their mouthpiece ratio.
If you do end up receiving the shot and with the mouth closed and couldn't,
you know,
holding it together.
That's one of the main things for sure.
It would make sure that they're buying into the mouth piece so we get them out
of pieces that you can breathe through the center of the hole right from
unbreakable Hector and the Victorville.
I think it makes the best mouthpieces I'm breaking down.
He makes a double an upper and lower.
When you breathe out on the top of the bottom of your teeth through dollar does
lock into place.
But for mine specifically,
I blow air child through the center and I think Tina,
do you have yours?
No.
Yeah,
it's not a double.
It's a single mouse,
but it's got like a little like a gap underneath that where you can breathe with
your mouth shut.
Oh that's very smart.
Bottom teeth just don't connect.
Okay.
That's very smart.
The devils that are payment.
Yeah,
the doubles are weird.
You can't talk to them and they used to have that power.
One member that was there were saying that it makes you like whips or something
like that makes you stronger,
makes you like less.
That's what I need.
That balance or something that they actually say that your draw alignment does
have some impact on what,
how strong you are.
Like I think there's a science behind it.
Like if you have your mouth open,
he tried dead lifts,
tried dead lift,
like oh I think
literally you're not as strong as if you fucking clamped down.
I don't think I've ever dead lift with her mouth open and maybe you should try
it.
Be Interesting to find out that works.
It might be bullshit and you know it might be,
but I think I read that.
I think.
How long did it take for your nose to heal when you got that long?
Man,
I was rolling six weeks later.
I had a great doctor,
his name was Dr Feinberg.
He retired unfortunately use out here in California,
but he did an amazing job and they use foam now.
So it used to be the nightmare was getting the packing out that pulling the
packing.
I was incredibly painful.
Like Lorenzo Fertitta had it that way and he said that he was like,
like someone was like raking his brain really intensely painful when they pull
the packing out,
when it's over,
they keep it in your nose for like a couple of days or something or a week or
whatever the fuck it is.
I actually think it changed the structure and I know they made it wider because
they'd put the cut the inside of it,
the the tuber with a fucking things call those turbinate or terminate turf
terminators,
whatever things inside.
So they scraped them down and then he put these splints in that like,
why didn't my opening,
I kept the splints in for like,
I dunno like a couple of weeks or whatever,
but after it was open,
after he cut out the scar tissue and terminators,
what are those things where some trim that down?
It was actually like a wider passage.
I want to get to.
It's great.
I feel like bill,
my cardio would be better.
[inaudible] hundred percent there's no doubt about it.
It will be,
but then you've got to realize you're gonna get hit in the nose.
Yeah,
that's,
I wouldn't talk to a doctor and he,
I actually got something done on my nose.
I don't know exactly what he's called,
but he scraped it like you're talking about.
And then he shocked with radio frequency.
Electricity is supposed to shrink to tissue and it takes like six weeks for it
to work.
That's interesting.
My nose is a little bit better,
I guess,
you know,
but,
uh,
I want to get like the full thing done.
I think I need to do after the next fight.
I've seen pictures of people that did that,
did it online where they showed all the meat that they cut out of their nose.
The scar tissue gets fucking crazy.
Do you think it will mess with the structural integrity of your nose?
Your nose is still a strong yes.
Yeah,
absolutely.
it does.
It's one of the doctors was saying that he,
I mean obviously it's the doctor's opinion from different,
from different,
uh,
but he was saying that he thinks of the structural integrity of nose would be
worse.
I don't think so.
I mean I think,
look,
you know,
this week anyway,
this little fucking thing,
you get shinned in that thing.
It's not,
I mean,
whether it's strong,
I mean when it's in perfect condition,
it's weak.
It's fuck.
So go on it from there and then also go on it from like the goal is to not get
hit in the face,
so let's,
let's have an extra incentive and then now your cardio is going to be like a
good percentage better,
which is way more important.
That's,
you just don't do what Vandelay did.
Randall,
he got his homeboy,
he had to get his whole fucking,
that was a perfect example of a guy who had to get his whole face reconstructed.
Yeah.
He had to get his eyebrows scraped down because I was told him different cots
had massive scar tissue.
They had to remove it and that.
Yeah.
But next was not nearly as extreme extreme.
Nick got his,
his uh,
his shit shaved down,
but they would put it back together again.
He still looked like normal Vandelay they had to like Rome.
I'm a normal guy.
Yeah.
I mean just saying they um,
with Vandelay they had to actually take a chunk of his ribs and create a piece
of cartilage and the rebuild his
nose,
his nose was flat.
Dude,
that's the,
that's from not moving your head
rolling and not moving your hand forward.
That was one of things.
I actually have a cauliflower into my note cause he's just how I went to my
buddy in the belly one time when he need and my nose is swollen up and it went
in with the center of it just put up with blood hard.
They're hard and yet just like your ear at cauliflower ear,
it's the same.
They went in Atlanta and all this blood just came rushing out and then they
filled it with look like a shoelace and it was up.
They stepped up in there to suck up the blood and you know,
a little gaps.
And that was for one of my Q one fights,
you know,
however long ago that was,
I don't know,
six,
seven years ago,
and then I should say recently,
but about three years ago,
I haven't know,
scraped down.
Actually they went in there and then he said that the sermon nose was like a
snowball in my nose,
so he,
he was scared to take more out and my nose would collapse,
which they put on a little luck.
Okay,
cool.
Plastic,
orange,
orange slice on.
I'm up in there to keep it structurally sound while it healed.
Yeah.
And then they pulled him out.
It's coming out of my brain.
I was nice.
Yeah.
I got to have it done against my nose.
I still can't breathe through one nostril.
The other one's good though,
so you can make sure I have the map.
It's this shitty design.
Yeah.
I mean,
why is it a week?
It's on the front of your face.
It's not designed to get punched in the head like man,
like a lot of accidents.
I don't know for designers,
well,
I broke mine without,
I broke mine when I was five I fell down a flight of stairs and I just smashed
my nose on the stair and from then on it was locked.
I guess that's why we have the option of be dry mouth as well I guess.
But what a shit design.
Yeah,
because once it got,
I didn't realize how important it wasn't till I got it fixed and then once I got
to fix like the idea of being able to breathe my mouth shut,
it was impossible to me.
I'd never known it might wake up with dry mouth in the morning.
Wow.
And all of a sudden I'm like,
this is awesome.
Nice.
Yeah.
I could be like that for awhile.
Then it came back again,
like I would go to yoga class and they would tell me I'm doing it wrong.
Like you have to breathe in through your nose,
out through your mouth.
I can't,
it doesn't work.
The shit doesn't work.
Yeah.
I was racing my wife with blown up balloons with half for one of our,
one of our kids' birthdays and she was just smashed me and I couldn't figure out
why I was opening my mouth.
I was breathing,
you know,
breathing the air through my nose.
So just slowing down the process by half.
So she was just smashed me on that,
blown up until I'm blown up drill.
I had to take it out of did I just one I had to figure in adapt.
What do you think about all these new technologies that are coming along that
are,
we had Ian Mccall on,
he was talking about some shit.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I was talking about,
well some,
some altitude thing.
It's,
it's what it does is it mimics sounded crazy man.
Yeah.
Sounded really,
it mimics,
it's a c Vac pod is what it's called and it does something with like changing
the altitude inside the container and it just like,
uh,
it makes a massive difference in your body's ability to assimilate oxygen other
than I'm going to up for trying anything.
You know what I mean?
If it's someone says it works like,
oh,
I need to try this out.
You know what I mean?
Well,
Ian's no bullshit or he's crazy,
but he's no bullshit.
And when he's talking about,
he said it was better than a hyperbaric chamber,
which is,
I know the hyperbaric chamber man.
Yeah,
I hurt my shoulder.
Nothing on my cardio.
Like I did it for injury.
I got better faster,
but my cardio was insanely good when I started sitting in the hyperbaric
chamber.
Like I noticed a big difference.
Yeah,
I've,
I've heard amazing results as far as like the ability to heal.
I wish I could afford to be in it all the time.
Really.
Dude.
I would do it if I could do it once a week,
if not more.
I would do it.
Just don't they make them,
well,
you can get it for the gym.
They know they're,
they're not,
they're not the heart chambers.
They're the soft chambers.
They don't work as well.
You can't get as much hundred like the heart chambers is 100% oxygen and they
can put you down to like two atmospheric pressures to be low.
You know,
and,
and the soft chambers,
they can't do that.
So it doesn't work as well.
It works,
but not as well as the heart chambers.
What is the variation?
What do you mean between how much better the heart chamber works so much better.
I don't even know exactly,
but I've done a little bit of a soft chambers in the heart.
I can tell big difference when I'm sitting in the heart chamber.
And where would you go to do that if you go to a chiropractor?
No,
I uh,
there's a place,
there's places to do hyperbaric chambers.
That's what they do.
They just only do,
have very chambers and uh,
it was in Sacramento.
Um,
I got prescribed through it from my physical therapist.
He's the one that told me about it on the stupid expensive.
Oh yeah,
like a hundred grand or something crazy.
Oh,
he had to buy one of them.
Yeah,
maybe a couple hundred thousand dollars.
And then you got to fill the oxygen all the time.
So for me,
if I went and go and do an hour and a half dive,
I found the cheapest place to do it and it's still 200 bucks per hour and a
half.
Wow.
That was always good about Colorado at the high altitude.
Going to go your pressure though.
That was the pressure.
So it's 100% oxygen and the pressure is supposed to be like speeds up the
molecules of healing and then all the way your body absorbs the oxygen.
I can't even tell you the science behind it,
but all's I know is that it works dude and it's supposed to be great for your
brain.
Wow.
Yeah.
I've heard nothing but amazing.
I felt like my handwriting got better when I was sitting there.
I started signing so I was like,
Oh Dang my hand.
Right.
I mean it could just be coincidence can use.
That
sucks.
Yeah,
but this is supposed to be according to at least Corny Ian.
This is even better.
It's called cyclical cyclical variations in adaptive conditioning.
See Vac and it's some crazy pod that you,
you lay in and using proprietary patterns,
sequences,
pressure is increased and decreased to simulate low altitudes in high altitudes.
And as pressure increases,
the volume of oxygen in the air and naturally increases is thicker and warmer
and as pressure decreases,
the volume of oxygen naturally diminishes.
And the air is thinner and cooler.
And they hypothesize that these changes simulate,
stimulate an individual's natural adaptation response to environment.
And the experience is unique to the individual,
but it's apparently has massive effects on a healing.
And there's even scientific findings that were published and a in,
in medical literature.
So it's not like just crazy nonsense that some wacky dude,
let's try that.
Very many places to do this,
right?
I don't think so.
I think there's only a few.
Um,
he was saying that there's,
let's look,
okay,
well it looks like locations.
Clearly there's only one way to survive chem trails.
You have to get into machine.
This is what the elites were using to protect themselves from the barium being
sprayed.
Whoa.
It's crunching and it doesn't seem like it's a good idea.
Well that's cause you're not a doctor.
You sick.
We'd given out fucking advice.
I hope your body's stronger than that water.
So there's,
there's several of these things in North America,
there's nine locations,
uh,
in the California area.
Oh Wow.
Anything in northern,
I'm trying to find it.
This,
this website sucks.
A fat one boy,
you have terrible website.
You fuck heads and you locations.
How much is his list phone numbers instead of having this stupid map that you
have to zoom in and out of.
This is terror.
When there was the websites you've fuckheads you should go.
You guys should go to Squarespace shit together.
So there's one in a private residence in Redmond,
Washington.
Why would you say that?
He will tell us where this dude lives.
So you're knocking on his door.
Yo Bro.
My fucking ankle.
Heart easy machine.
Can I borrow your shit side?
It says nine,
nine locations here.
Zoom in for details.
I don't always do the man bitch,
why isn't it not?
Let me,
he's gonna man cause it sucks cause your website sucks with that one.
Oh now I'm in Spain.
I zoomed in and I'm experience.
How about fuck you?
How about fuck?
Fuck you dummies.
I don't really believe that.
I don't mean fuck you.
I'm just saying that for effect through macro effective,
they'll listen to this.
He was talking really great about our product,
but then we started criticizing our website and it really hurt my feelings.
If those MMA guys,
I think they get aggressive when they get together.
Definitely MMA guys,
product of your surroundings.
Like we were a train at the gym.
I felt like I was gangster.
I'm pretty relaxed.
Yeah,
well you get gangster when you teach it.
I love it.
Yeah,
he does,
man.
You gotta watch out this stuff.
Well you obviously love it,
you know,
and that's exactly what you need.
It's,
I think it's such a amazing thing.
The ability to sort of mold young fighters and that for a guy like me who loves
martial arts as an art,
you know,
as an art form,
I'm real good.
It really is an art form.
I know people go when you're injuring people,
it smells like water color asshole.
Yeah,
but you're good enough to do it.
To not injure people too.
You know what I mean?
Good enough at the art to where you could do it without injuring someone.
You could,
you could defense defend yourself without hurting someone.
Well,
sure,
if a dork attacked you,
like say if some dude who was like really good at dungeons and dragons and it
fucking went spazz on you and rushed you,
I'm going to bite him.
Having in my head,
if you know,
if it ever came to the point,
you know,
outside of the gym or the cage or something,
I had a fight in the street or defend myself,
chuck them out,
choked my,
or just punched him in the gut.
Like how many normal people actually get punched in the gut.
You know,
just knocked the wind out of him.
You'd would have to be really diligent.
Like you don't want to just tee off on some asshole because he started a fight
with you.
It's so hard to repress that.
But we've all been in a situation where some drunk dude is clearly fucked up,
was talking so much shit.
And you're like,
I could just uncork one on this guy's face and you know he's not going to see it
coming,
but you can't do that the best way to,
I mean you,
you'll get in trouble.
I'll get in trouble man.
Yeah,
of course.
Not only that and they,
I just fucking pulled up the mma.com and fucking mixed martial arts.com and
ceremonies in trouble for that.
He had kicked some do it on a dot.
Oh,
I got stupid with them.
There was some,
uh,
throw a head kick.
Yeah,
apparently shitting them.
That's the rumor I'm talking Shit Donald,
I'm sorry if I got the details wrong,
but I think Brian Collin told me head kicked somebody.
Maybe if somebody else called me,
I tried to put myself in those scenarios.
You know,
I'm just even the around the element of that.
I mean,
if you're beating someone up on the street and you said do a habit,
what else?
Huge fucking mistake out of all the people to fuck with on a dock.
You look at this skinny dude with a cowboy hat,
man,
fuck you and your fucking boat faggot and next thing you know
that shit,
it bounces off the side here.
We're going to do something pretty bad too.
It's,
he's pretty cool,
dude.
He had pissed him off pretty bad,
but this is all a lot of Douche bags up for sure.
It's very unfortunate.
It's really hard to develop a human being.
I think you know that and I know that it's how much it's changed me.
You bullet.
It absolutely does,
right?
I've had to hold this guy back a couple of times,
you know what I mean?
He's almost always get into fights.
Holy Do,
oh,
anywhere.
It was just,
I just feel people should respect one another and help each other out and when
it doesn't happen,
I'm just like,
this guy's kind of a dick face.
Then I'll speak up about it and then people get mad sometimes.
Yeah.
Well there's a lot of Dick faces out there and they don't like to hear that.
People don't like to be criticized.
It's hard.
Did someone calls you a,
they may be a dick face that lady and you're like,
yeah,
you're right.
You know,
it's fucking hard.
It's like admitting you know something you know about Rod's,
it's like,
it's like so many things like being wrong sucks.
People don't like being wrong.
So the argue,
like there's a guy named Michael Shermer is his famous skeptic who has this very
interesting quote about smart people defending dumb ideas.
And it,
the smart people,
there's a lot of very intelligent people that believe really stupid things.
And the reason being is that they're smart enough to convince themselves that
they're right.
Okay.
Yeah.
And this smart enough to defend that stupid thing.
And it's kind of an interesting point of view,
but it makes sense.
It's fucking hard for people to say they're wrong.
So as something that's good,
uh,
a good talent for an athlete as well,
whether you have the skills or not believe that you have the skills to win the
fight to win the world title,
to put yourself through that.
When I think also as a fighter,
it's super important to be absolutely objective about your skillset.
You can't,
like we were talking about observing fights and watching fights and you have to
be objective,
yet you can't say,
you know,
hey,
I'm watching Tj Dillashaw.
I love that dude.
So I'm looking at him in a way that's not,
I'm just looking at everything's perfect,
it's beautiful.
I'm just loving watching him win,
Eh,
that's not the right way to do it.
And you know that.
So you'd have to step back and you,
okay,
is there,
what is he doing wrong and how do I get my,
my friendship out of the way and then look at this subjectively.
That's why,
you know,
I do have the fighters watch the film.
I am abundant Colorado.
Mike Tempo watches the film and it actually kind of happened by accident.
Said I watched the film,
I'll make notes.
And then the same fight again
while I was high and it realized that I made notes.
So I made notes again.
And then I looked at the notes.
I had two sets of notes.
One.
I remember being high and one I remember not being high and realized there was a
difference.
Now was there a difference because they just watch it the second time or the
third time or whatever time it was or was the difference because of wheat.
So I was like,
well fuck man,
maybe there's something to this.
So I started watching the fights while sober walls,
Highland school,
fuck man on sponsors me,
it ticks him off for brain ticks.
My friend watched it again,
just to compare notes just to make sure it is.
I mean I want to make sure I'm making the best decisions for them.
Can you also make this,
whether you're awake or whether you're tired?
Many elements that could change my view,
my perspective on that particular fight,
everything.
Right.
Whether you enjoy a song,
like you have to be in the right mood for the right kind of stuff.
There's a lot of different kinds of music that I'm sure we all like you were
looking at.
Yeah.
It's like it's not even a good,
it's like now's a good time for that.
Like sometimes I don't wanna watch fights.
Sometimes I want to watch a fucking curbing enthusiasm.
Hey,
sometimes I'll leave a fuck.
He's like talking about professionals and split second opening with this fuck
they got to really be on your toe.
One thing I do believe weed has a lot of benefits to it and I started because I
had was getting nature injuries and I didn't want to actually take the pain
pills I was being prescribed for my surgeries.
So that's what I started,
you know,
investigating weed and marijuana and I would help that to calm me down.
I want her to talk to you about that.
Yes,
because that's another issue that I think is really important.
The good dogs,
I keep hearing about fighters that are having problems with payment.
I think a hundred percent people are just thinking,
oh,
I had back to back,
major fucking surgeries lined up and then I broke my job or my ankle tore up my
knee.
I had my neck surgery,
I had like a couple of good ones,
woke my hand a couple of times.
So I've had multiple fucking surgeries.
One here.
A good one actually it's this long time ago is when bosses training for Kendall,
Kevin Randleman.
He came to Colorado for health,
the two training and that was one of his main sparring partners and I'm like I'm
not one one 55 we were just scrapping it.
I'm trading with my other guy.
My other buddy killed Tucker Komatsu who's a Japanese kitchen,
kitchen karate black belt and I was sparring.
I threw around kicking he to a front kick while it's in the round kick.
The issue was I was not wearing my cup.
Oh my right ball actually broke.
So I had my buddy Oscar Martinez throw me in the car.
I didn't go down on this.
I still stood my ground.
I got in the car,
I'm having my buddy Oscar take me like going opposite directions of one ways and
stuff and got me to the hospital and they did like an emergency or emergency
surgery.
So lesson learned here.
Where a cup gentlemen,
I know what I do is I take it,
you were talking about the cup issue on stuff and the fights.
I take a one,
it was tie cups is still tie cup and they put that in a regular envelope,
like a shock doctor envelope cup and just put that on and I put tight shorts
over that,
the hold it in place,
the shorts that warm my Kim,
the cage fight would say little boss on them.
I still wore those for every fight,
kickboxing and MMA.
He was like my lucky shorts.
So I put my still cup in my shock doctor envelope and then put that on and then
have my pet shorts over that and then in my fight shorts.
So it's what I always,
she ever tried diamond dude,
they're awesome.
They're awesome diamonds.
Incredible.
And they just released a new improved version of it for folks who never heard of
it.
If you're,
if you're doing Jujitsu or anything,
I seriously this they,
it's
a compression short that they have this really well designed cop that fits in
this videos on the website of the dude take and tie kicks,
then nuts.
And so really?
Yeah.
For me it's a,
it's a made a huge difference in Jujitsu.
It took my boss completely out of the equation.
Yeah.
You can't even finish armors if you're not wearing a cup most of the time.
Yeah,
they fucking hurts.
that's true.
So one of the things,
I started getting major injuries and then getting surgeries and I didn't want to
take the pain pills,
although I did take some of them and I had broke my jaw.
I was taking a liquid,
some kind of liquid pain pill.
I know what it was,
but that's what started my venture in the wheat.
So it was just to get through the night so I could sleep.
But it does fuck in my memory man.
Like I was having like the next day have an issue like holding combinations for
these guys and stuff and just not remembering dates and stuff.
So it did fuck with me personally.
I call it my memory and I don't think it's for everybody cause I'm very,
very high strong and tried to get shit done all it not try and get shit done on
all the fucking time.
So I think if somebody always already can predisposed to be a slight bit lazy,
this is not for you.
100% hey,
like we,
it's not free.
Right.
I mean it affects him differently though.
Like he'll,
he'll,
he can enjoy five time.
Yeah.
I'm not kidding you.
It does it sometimes.
Yeah Dude,
it's like a reverse effect.
Like most people get stoned though the sit on the couch so get hungry,
not want to go start doing combos and shit.
This guy's shadow boxing and really tight.
But you know what?
I figured
things out about my body when I'm high.
I figured out certain stretches that I need.
Like I've,
I feel like I'll be like,
Ooh,
you know what?
I'm tight right here.
Look I've,
I've figured shit out.
And then as you're like,
you're feeling your body more,
I'd like,
you know what?
I got to incorporate that more.
And then like certain techniques,
like kicking techniques,
like I've gone over them high and I like feel the weight transfer better because
you know how like when you shit in a bag,
when you,
when you really whip your hip into it,
there's certain times you get it perfect.
And there's certain times where it's a little off,
a little weird,
but then there's times when you just feel it and you just shoot.
You just got that one.
Yeah,
it felt different.
I felt that you today you can fucking kids were dickens kicks in with awesome.
We're doing a like some basic footwork drills and stuff and it's not what you
typically would do for you personally.
So we get to play a girl was like,
can we do some kicks?
All right,
fucking while.
I'm like,
Holy Shit,
why am I say fuck you couldn't fricking kicked me.
And I already know this from like this making videos and stuff that I got it.
I got it.
Video also demonstrating the,
the,
the sponge cake.
So that was,
that was awesome.
Thanks man.
Please.
Thank you man.
It was for fun.
But yeah,
I've been doing,
I've been kicking shit.
Yeah,
it was a big fucking awesome.
You could fucking kick your an athlete for sure.
Well it's just that spot my body developed doing that.
I mean I didn't,
I was a boy when I learned how to kick so I might,
I was all like,
yeah,
that's what I was talking about.
Like the dexterity,
the ability to move your body and assurance.
You are an amazing kicker,
but you are having a hard time.
Like when I was trying to show you acts kicks or I was trying to spin kicks.
Yep.
It's an awkward way for you to move.
That's my body's done that since I was a child.
Ballet Dwayne Bang.
If he's laying down and don't start slapping,
I mean not a hard like [inaudible] army.
So cool man.
I come already
training him to do what he wants.
You know,
people always asking me is dwindling going to be a fighter.
I lived way Megan.
I'm like,
if you choose the two,
whatever's passion is going to be,
I'm like,
I'm going to support him.
He tap dances.
That's good.
That's beautiful.
I see.
Even if he's going to be best,
I would have had if I had a gay son,
as long as he was happy,
I would way rather have a gay happy song than a dead daughter or depressed
straight son or wa happy.
So you can really give a fuck about like if your kid,
like I joke around about my daughter being a lesbian and my wife gets upset.
It's like,
don't say that.
I go,
why?
what if she likes Batman?
She likes wrestling.
She wrestles all the time.
She's super aggressive.
Two daughters,
one of them is like really very girly and a the other one,
I have a 17 year old as well,
but he's much more creative and artistic.
That's my daughter.
The youngest one is a fucking brute man.
She's hyper aggressive.
She like leaps off the bed and like she takes my back,
right?
And she's three and I'm like,
she's a lesbian and my wife's like,
stop it.
But I'll be like,
look,
if you,
if you love lesbians,
okay,
I,
I have zero problem with people being gay.
So why would I care and lesbian like it's really kind of like not even
criticizing society,
little by assholes,
but it's not like being a gay man when you get beat up.
Who gets beat up for being a lesbian does.
I mean I'm sure someone has been,
so I apologize if you have fuck fucking household,
but the reality is even straight guys love lesbians.
You know,
everybody loves lesbians.
Lesbians can kiss in public.
Nobody gives a shit.
They go,
whoa.
You know it's a few country girls like and like it damaged.
You can't tell she's a lesbian this early.
That's far as I can.
I'm just joking dude.
But it's a lot of shit.
I say that's not true.
You understand that.
You say it a lot though.
You don't say it in front of herb.
You fire like specific cheeses.
He's just telling her just you're going to be a lesbian.
You're going to be,
he loves mermaids and flowers.
It's a joke.
I'm very curious to see what my children were going to,
they're going to turn it to become or what they,
what they are now and if they're going to have expressed that as an adult,
like I'm pretty sure it loads when it makes going to be a fighter.
He's already had his gloves and,
and was training in the gym all the time.
Him and Tj are best buddies.
He knows that.
He knows favor.
He goes paper and Tj and buckles and so he knows the fighters of the Jimmy
Lesbian at the gym.
He loves the martial arts.
He's got his own little mouthpiece.
He's a little bit OCD bus things already.
You know,
from my daughter,
my daughter at j,
she's an artist.
She's just drawing and coloring all the time.
So that's,
as I tell her,
we a,
we're all artists,
you know,
she's,
we're martial artists and she's an actual artist,
so,
you know,
it's good.
I want to,
hopefully when they get older they can express,
it can be who they want to be and I'd be stuck in some shitty job that that's
her unhappy with.
Yeah.
That's why I'm always fucking happy with,
I get to basically do what I want every day.
You know,
finding something that you can express yourself in what?
And it's whatever you gravitate towards.
If it's fucking flower arrangements,
I mean,
whatever the fuck it is,
man.
I don't know what makes someone like a certain kind of music.
Like I don't like the grateful dead man.
I,
I don't,
I've tried.
I don't like it.
It doesn't mean I hate people.
I love a lot,
lot of love,
a lot of friends who love the grateful dead.
That's fine,
but it's for whatever.
It doesn't fucking work with me.
You know,
like,
I like Dwight Yoakam.
I'm like a lot of shit.
If you,
Fran of the dental is a friend of mine,
I'll be high.
Um,
they actually played that on the helicopter ride that I went on in Maui and I
was like,
are you doing this to me?
Fuck,
that was good.
I was actually a podcast fan,
so shout out to our driver who was kind of weird.
How about a podcast fan?
Flies around and Allison talk about the podcast at the helicopter.
I was awesome.
The,
oh it's in say Maui.
We were,
I was in Maui last week.
That's why there was no a podcast.
But uh,
me and my family went on a,
a flight on a helicopter over Malakai and Malakai only has like a couple
thousand people on the whole island.
And a lot of them are like campers.
They just go there and camp cause they can live there for free and they live off
the land.
They fish and they hunt and there's this fresh guava and mangoes and all these
different plants are just growing there.
And they hunt,
excuse me,
how wild pigs and there's wild sheep and all these sorts of different animals
that you can like the hunt and fish and eat fresh fruits everywhere.
And apparently people go there and they take a boat and they just stay there for
months and months at a time.
And it's legal.
Well I should have an affiliate in Hawaii so hopefully I get to go there and a
good to my seminar,
Mike Vickers.
So I got,
I feel like talk throughout the U.
It's actually have an affiliate in Thailand also.
So that's,
that's a photo that I took from a on my incident when we were flying up or
malice.
Right.
Tahanto almost.
Yeah,
that's the way,
like different islands.
That was,
I think,
I'm pretty sure that was when we were,
we got to Malakai.
We flew over Maui and then we went to Malakai.
And this is,
this is in Maui.
This is um,
one of the craters that you fly over.
It's fucking insane.
It's insane because like Hawaii looks incredibly beautiful from the ground.
You know,
you just get out of your car and you're like,
wow,
it was amazing.
But when you're above it and you realize how weird it is,
like did this thing just popped up out of them,
but ocean and that really what it is,
the volcano,
it's like one of the biggest mountain in the world by volume.
It just happens to be in the middle of the ocean and it's just fucking volcano.
Just jot it out in the middle of the 5,000 miles to five hours by plane from
everywhere.
Like there's nowhere to go,
like you eat and he's crazy.
Polynesian.
Motherfuckers got there on boats.
Crazy.
That's why they're so tough.
Gangster.
Yeah,
it's probably just part of it for sure.
They got their 1500 years ago,
man.
Wow.
1500 years ago.
These fucking guys got there by bus and they did it more than once.
They knew how to navigate the ocean back then 1500 fucking years ago and they
made these boats,
dude,
they have like there's a an aquarium and Maui where you can go see the boats
that they created.
Like they have a replica of them.
It's a fucking log.
Wow.
Fucking law.
It's a hollowed out logs and they had like a like gnats that they created that
they made themselves and they would just,
and they would take a year,
I took a year to make a fucking net and they would like set these nets and just
just go out there and hope that they would catch enough fish to keep their
fucking children alive.
Because it took you a year to build that knit,
go 1500 miles.
By canoe.
I mean,
could you even cover 10 miles a day?
How many miles are you covering?
A day canoeing.
Yeah.
What do you think?
How much you think,
forget the place in Ohio used to be,
I think like seven.
I mean she should be,
you should be able to canoe more than you can walk.
And I just last last five days,
walked 120 miles up in the rubies,
right?
That's right.
He was just saying that you're deer hunting experience.
So how many,
how many miles do you think you can canoe?
Should we say?
If you're really going gangster a hundred miles a day,
I'm not quite sure what it's going to be.
Tired.
I mean,
do you mean touch it?
It's like a boat or a bike.
Streambed downstream when dry,
you've got to deal with those.
So let's say best case scenario,
you're going gangster and while you're catching fish and feeding your family,
you're going a hundred miles a day.
Wow.
It'll take you 15 fucking days to get all the way out there in the middle of the
ocean and fun home.
Then how many calories would you need to do that as well and then make it,
oh
great.
A couple of key factors in that
being sane,
15 days at gangster paddling.
I did five days of it.
It's like your work,
go hunt with a Steve Rinella for that show meter.
And we went down the Missouri and we paddled like most of the way.
Oh it was fucking,
it was a brutal workout.
Great.
Like your shoulders get sore,
you can,
you could treat it as a workout and really get gangster with it.
And you know,
really felt like I was treating it as a workout.
I was like,
I'm just not going to like just paddle our way and enjoy the scenery.
I'm not working out why I'm here,
so let's get a workout in.
So just like made it a race.
Brian Cowen was
rushing that full.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'm going to win this shit.
Yeah.
That's one thing I was,
the marijuana helped me to relax and we'll be looking at things so many
different,
you know,
look at things so differently now.
Well not now.
I actually stopped weed for a while now.
So it was kind of debating on if I was taking too much or what strand or weapon.
You know,
it definitely allowed me to appreciate life.
We're able to relax and you know,
play with the kids a bit more and you know,
food tastes better,
drinks taste better.
I can relax.
I'm going to OCD and about shit that I can't control right now.
So you know how to clean neat it possibly.
You know what man,
if I'd say the line to the fucking my memory,
you know what I'm holding myths with these guys and he's Today's modern day
fucking inches right here.
So if I miss them,
they punched me in the face,
you know,
that's going to be an issue.
So I gotta be on point with things for sure.
Even though I tell the guys,
even if I do all the myths on the wrong side,
the striker needs to control their strike and that's just the way it has to be.
So,
um,
you know,
it's just one of those things,
but I won't tell him that for them.
I'm a big Fan of light edibles.
Lycos edibles.
That's what I've been doing lately.
How many milligrams?
Talking crazy.
See that's the problem man.
You bought these fucking cookies from these assholes,
you don't know what to call it.
Colorado.
Colorado is pretty consistent on point.
Yeah.
Well it,
it's consistent and on point with like certain shit like go to la speed weed.
They have these gummy bears.
You can guarantee where are you ready?
My speed.
We'd LASP wheeze.
Gummy bears have a spa and if you know it and you're used to it,
you might want to bite one in half.
You might want to eat the whole one based on so many other things other than
just the content.
How much did you eat your hydration levels?
Edge,
which was like so many.
I fit factors that yours?
No way to personal tolerance to personal time.
If you eat it a lot,
you can do a lot more than a person who doesn't.
What would you think of this as far as marijuana?
You think that's for now?
I mean like you're gonna say no,
of course.
Cause that's the correct answer.
But it's not for everybody like send out,
which shouldn't be fucking smoking week.
Some people are just dumb fucks you.
And I'm not the smartest guy either.
I'm not,
you know,
like I'm,
I'm,
I went to high school and that was it.
Like no college education.
But I definitely be able to pursue what I felt was quiz correct for me and my
path being a wash.
Laundry.
You love what you do.
I fucking love what I do.
How many times have I not said that?
I think it's nothing's for everybody.
The orange juices for everybody.
Yeah.
So I think that it means to be a test.
You know,
sweets aren't shoot peanuts is
people might like orange juice not be able to fucking tolerate it either.
Exactly.
So that's problem.
I give her an apple juice.
She goes crazy.
She loves it.
Yeah.
Puts users their favorite porn.
She sucks.
Fucking looks at you.
Try to figure a shit sandwich.
Yeah.
Look,
it's not for everybody.
Coconuts enough.
I love coconut water.
I've given it to people and they want to throw up.
So that's going to be,
that's got to be a thing as far as you know,
legalizing it,
you know,
for sure.
I think people should be able to make their own decisions.
But man,
you know there are,
there are reasons for it for rules and guidelines and such.
Cause some people just need to be told what to do and what not to do.
I don't agree with that.
I don't think people are going to run out in guidelines.
I think there has to be counseling cause some people just don't fucking know
right or wrong.
Well I think there should be for special occasion for sure.
And I know sort of education.
Do we look,
we're dealing with very complicated issues where you're altering human
neurochemistry through,
through psychedelics.
Whether it's,
you mean people don't want to think of marijuana as a psychedelic.
It is without a doubt a psychoactive substance.
And if you eat it in large doses,
it's as psychedelic is anything.
If you don't believe that you're fucked because if you do take it and you,
you're not ready,
you're going to get an experience very unlike,
you know,
very unlike like a regular like chicks get high smoke a joint.
So I think that anything like that can fuck you up and anything that could fuck
you up mentally we should tread with caution.
And because of the fact that we don't have education,
we don't have centers where someone can go and they can say,
well just trolled environment,
you and your friends.
What we'd like to do is we're going to bring you in here.
We have a very specific level of marijuana we're going to give you and when a
work you up to where we think you can handle it.
So you could be in a comfortable,
safe environment.
Like have you guys gone to the marijuana on fucking treatment center?
Yeah.
One of the fucking is,
yeah.
It's turns out I'm good with one gummy bear.
One gummy bears.
Perfect.
You know,
I found out what it is,
you know,
we went too far one day and I started thinking about my childhood and it was a
little fucked up.
But I think I learned from that too.
But this way at least you would get an educated experience and we don't,
now we're like figuring it out for ourselves.
Whereas if you buy Tylenol,
you know what the fucking doses,
it's real simple.
It's right there on the label.
I take four Advils when I got a headache,
you know,
you know what the fuck you're supposed to take 800 milligrams.
Some people don't.
Some people are just retarded.
Anything can be abused.
You know,
I've,
I've trained too much.
Like I,
I didn't really know my reserve.
I was pushed too hard and broke my own body down.
Like I have low test.
We were talking about,
I have like,
I have my testosterone checked.
I was one o one o five or one or three I forgot,
like super fucking loud.
That's crazy.
That's just from,
you know,
from,
I understand if you're not,
was totally in ways that,
you know,
head trauma,
severe weight,
cutting,
red lining your body.
And then of course,
uh,
steroids or team to my steroids.
We need to,
I've got three of the four fucking symptoms right there.
Head trauma,
severe way cutting and red lining your body.
So and jerking off like a maniac.
Paul shooting off a zoo monkey on heroin.
Yeah,
that could do it too.
I will drain your balls,
your ball park.
It's the thing that's 10 minutes,
10 minutes,
10 minutes to turn into a Pumpkin Kale.
Nice.
Can I plug my,
can I plugged my affiliate real quick?
Fuck yeah.
Oh Man.
Okay.
So Wayne bang.com so where they can go and find [inaudible] dot com yes.
Then I got some affiliates.
I just didn't have my,
my buddy Alberto crane,
Burbank,
you know,
Alberta to become an affiliate and they got benched sister in Westminster,
Colorado.
We've got and who kept Thailand,
Mike Vickers in Hawaii.
Brian Boma and Yuma,
Arizona,
Jeff Fairbanks and Alaska and at James Henry and Radford,
Virginia.
I got James Johnson.
Okay.
What does the.com [inaudible] dot com go check it out.
yang.com and they have all of your affiliates up there and like you said before,
I think it's really interesting you,
you set up your,
your your structure for your lessons every week and then they poured that shit,
sent it out to them.
You've got to fill up their
belts and shit.
You don't have a ranking structure colored red,
white,
blue,
purple,
Brown,
black belt in Dwayne,
Bang.
Only one guy while the Mcdonald's and my a west coast east coast headquarters.
He said he's that Chris Herzog as well and they're a tough plan affiliate.
[inaudible] Tj Dillashaw.
He's actually going to blue belt.
Oh yeah.
So maybe soon maybe.
Then you're going to go brown,
black,
white,
Brown,
black.
Nice.
Yeah.
I got my shield laid out,
man.
I broke it down to a science and a structure.
That's a big thing about the hololens style,
the Dutch style of a Muy Thai panic.
I trained with rob came and a bunch of times.
Yeah.
Nice.
Robertson man.
I learned a lot from his actual VHS tapes they got from web century or whatever.
I used to watch those fuckers all the time.
I was really impressed at like,
like the way he structures his combinations.
It's very technical.
It's like,
you know,
left hook,
right leg kick this position.
That was the question.
The way you like,
you sort of picture it and then once you train with a guy who was explaining
that stuff to you,
then you watch a fight.
You could see it take place.
You know,
we watched like Remy one Joshkey Ski,
your wife's like certain time fighters and you go,
oh,
I see what he just did.
They're like,
there's a Ernesto hoost highlight reel where he,
to me,
he had the best left hook,
right leg combo ever.
He will just slap,
you know,
he would just set that up.
So beautiful.
Perfect.
Oh that was,
that was a good guy too.
He's cool.
I like it.
Very nice.
Very friendly.
But that,
that fucking leg kick highlight.
Pull that shit up.
We'll,
we'll close with this.
Pull that up on Youtube.
It's cool for me to Ernesto hoost leg kick highlight was cool for me is to be
such a fan of Ernesto and then with time in Japan and seen him and then he knew
who I was.
I was like,
Oh fuck man.
That's bad.
Yeah.
He knew who I was too.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
Yeah,
but I'm still a,
I'm a kickbox Dork.
Fuck yeah.
You get,
watch this.
You Watch
these fucking leg kicks man.
That's not it.
Oh yeah it is.
This is,
this is just the beginning of it before it actually shows the video.
This is just a showing the highlight and then it goes into this
part word.
Skipping ahead a little.
Here it is.
Watch these miracle.
Yeah.
He found Marco a couple of times.
Yeah,
it was cute.
One gets off on each other.
Yeah.
Basis man.
Jeez US backing up though,
Dude.
There's so Allie though really get hit with a baseball bat.
There's so Allie the in the way he chops town with it,
man.
Yeah.
Three quarters dropped and it's so like whip like,
I mean he would,
he was like,
he was hitting you with a fucking mace or something.
Here it is like Bernardo,
that fucking left hook,
right leg combo is so nasty and so beautiful to watch.
Like you want to talk about martial arts?
That mother fucker is a ballerina.
Yes.
I mean that shit is like way cooler than I think Barista cops ever done.
Look at that big bell cause this Cofina a big dude too many fast and that Combo
is so gorgeous.
The left hook,
right leg kick always over again with that Combo.
It's,
and he was shut mother fuckers down like Filo.
Look at him here.
He's like,
Jesus just sucked.
When that pops that beat him.
I was like,
I broke my heart man.
Well he got bum rushed by gorilla.
Yeah,
that's true.
Have you never seen that fight?
Sab didn't even look like a human being.
He was the biggest,
any fires there been.
Oh he was on everything that ever existed he was on,
he was 370 pounds of Mexican supplements just stacked into a man.
It's a beautiful thing though.
Again.
I mean I don't,
I don't think that it's good that Bob Sapp did that,
but I think that it's good that we got to see what happens when a guy that big
can do that can hit,
you know,
even a guy like Ernesto who is,
you can't stop that bum rush,
that big crazy fuck.
It was just going to fucking donkey Kong.
You went to the ground,
he did it.
He did it.
They did it with very little MMA experience.
Very little kickboxing you,
that's what,
that's what sucks with thousand breaks.
My heart man look up through it and that's because so much,
you know,
and then for him to get beat from somebody who's,
tend to get on paper not as good,
like that just sucks.
It shows you how gangster cro cop is a cop cause Krakoff finished him.
Especially back then.
Yeah,
I mean accuracy.
But he was also physically strong enough to keep the dude away,
push him off,
just pushed him.
And he was had this like aggressive style cro cop was also like,
he's like a sniper like leaps in and cracks you with shit.
Whereas like Ernesto would be more technical and would block shit.
You can't stand in front of that dude.
You just can't stand in front of us.
So a style like Morocco's will you like leap in with a head kick or leaping in
with one punch or one kick?
Just full block power blast.
Not as technical,
you know?
So when he fought,
he fought Ernesto.
It wasn't right style for Nesta
when he's like Bob Sapp is a better style.
I think there's also the fact that Bob had already fought a bunch of guys and
how long can you really keep that much supplements?
You know me and couple of elements,
there's never been a human that big inside of a ring show them show the picture
of Bob Sapp if you've never seen it.
So he's a sweetheart of a guy guy and it's really unfortunate.
And watching them fight now because it seems like he just goes down.
Oh,
he's still fighting.
He's lost like some insane amount of fights in a row that they made may get a
good chunk of change.
Now.
I don't think he did.
I think he also had a lot of problems.
Well,
I think he was making good money in Japan for a while,
but then I think he rented some problems with them.
And remember there was at one k one event where he wouldn't come out and fight.
They didn't prepare him or sent him to sign a contract before he fought.
Well,
yeah.
You know,
there was some Lukey fuck.
Are you kidding me?
Is that the biggest guys ever been inside the ring?
A human being right there.
It's the same for sure.
Three,
three 70 with abs three 73 70 with ABS.
God dammit.
Anyway,
look man.
Dwayne,
it's always a pleasure.
See You [inaudible] time.
Tj,
thank you very much for doing this and thanks for helping me out today man.
Really Sean Training.
It was really fun getting to see you.
Uh,
you're,
you move with them and kicked the bag and you technique looks fucking sweet.
I appreciate that.
He's a serious athlete.
Has just learn shit so quick,
like showing you one thing and watching you duplicate it and then two or three
times later it's like 50,
60% better.
Like that's beautiful to say.
You got the perfect environment for learning their team.
Alpha male bitches,
hell on the rise,
the bang,
bang.com ladies and Gentleman Twain,
bank.com you can get one of these super low and sexy tee shirts.
I got three of them,
bitch.
Good man.
Thank you brother.
Was three of those.
What's the endowment?
Dwayne Bang,
calm on Twitter and Tj Dillashaw on Twitter as well.
And Tj,
how you spell your name?
Last name is d,
I l l a s h a w n t j D.
I l l.
A s.
H.
A W as well as on Instagram.
Same name.
I love you buddy.
Thank you guys.
Thank you very much.
I love being your times.
Um,
all right,
we will be back tomorrow with a great Joey Coco Diaz and then Wednesday we
return with a Everlast in the monocoque and house bitch,
which should be a great time.
Uh,
okay,
so squarespace.com thanks to Squarespace,
use the code Joe Eight.
Save yourself 10% and on at.com go to o n n I t and use the code name Rogan,
and save yourself 10% of any and all supplements.
All right,
you guys,
thank you for all the love online.
And I say always,
but I really mean it like I benefit from this show as much as you guys do.
And so thank you to everybody tuning in and everybody's ever been on it.
All right,
your fucks.
We'll see you tomorrow.
Yay.